Herzlich Willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge 13. Heute zu Gast bei uns im Studio, Constanze Kurz, Informatikerin.
Na.
Und wir wollen über Plagiate reden, über aus naheliegenden Gründen. Wir kommen gerade von der Goodbye-Demo gegen unseren noch amtierenden Verteidigungsminister. Wenn wir Glück haben, wenn Fefe nicht hinemacht mit dem Schneiden, ist er schon zurückgetreten, bis wir diese Sendung draußen haben.
Oh, ich werd mich beeilen.
Das wäre jetzt aber schon schade.
Das passiert mir nicht. Nee, nee, nee.
Ja, also die Demo war ganz hübsch. Die Bilder sind auch mittlerweile, glaub ich, dann im Netz zu finden. Viele lustige Plakate, eine Menge Leute. Und warum wir über Plagiate reden wollen, ist, weil, nun ja, dieser Minister ist ja mit einem Monsterplagiat aufgefallen. Also er hat halt offensichtlich ganz große Teile seiner Doktorarbeit zusammenkopiert und da wollen wir ja mal ein bisschen darüber reden, warum das eigentlich so schlimm ist, was eigentlich die Folgen von Plagiat in der Wissenschaft sind und warum wir uns darüber so aufregen. Und fangen wir einfach vielleicht mal an, bei dem Ursprung von Plagiat ist ja eigentlich in der Wissenschaft doch irgendwie schon eher ein altes Phänomen.
Ja klar, man findet natürlich zu allen Jahrhunderten eigentlich irgendwelche Leute in der Wissenschaft, die plagiert haben und meistens war es früher so, dass es schon eine große Schande und Schmach war.
Wenn es dann entdeckt wurde.
Genau.
Ja, das ist ja immer noch so.
Naja, wie man nicht mehr so aktuell sieht. Es ist offenbar nicht für jeden eine Schande.
Naja, Quot, Lizet, Jovi.
Was bitte?
Quot, Lizet, Jovi, Non-Lizet, Bovi, kennst du nicht?
Nee, ich hatte kein Lateinspruch.
Ein ganz alter Lateinspruch, was die Jupiter erlaubt. Das ist noch lange nicht dem Oxen erlaubt.
Ah, verstehe.
Das kam noch nicht jetzt in der Bundestagsdebatte.
Echt, haben sie den Spruch gebracht? Nein.
Ich glaube, das war der Barge von der Linkspartei. Ich bin nicht ganz sicher, der hat den im Bundestag gebracht.
Das ist eigentlich so ein Spruch, was die Senatoren oder sagen wir mal, auf Deutschland gemünzt so die Freiherren von uns zubringen würden, um sich vom Pöbel zu distanzieren.
Er hat ja auch gleichzeitig gesagt, dass früher der Adel gewusst hätte, was er zu tun hat in einem solchen Fall.
Da gab es auch diverse Karikaturen zu.
Und Professor Lauterbach, der hat sich so richtig, hat sich wirklich sehr echauffiert, also von der SPD, der ist ja so ein Gesundheitsexperte, der im Bundestag sitzt, der hat ihm angemerkt, dass das wirklich auch persönliche Empörung war.
Ich glaube, er hat auch die Talkshows bereist. Und das fand ich sehr, ich habe mir so ein paar von diesen Talkshows gesehen, weil ich mir dachte, das Thema interessiert mich dann nochmal. Und da sind mir so ein paar Sachen aufgefallen. Also einer war, dass in einer Talkshow die These geäußert wurde und der ist auch nicht widersprochen worden, dass der ja eigentlich gar keinen Doktortitel braucht, weil er ja ein Freiherr ist oder was ist der Baron?
Ja, Freiherr von zu.
So und man braucht ja gar keinen Doktor, wenn man eh irgendwie Baron von und zu ist, weil dann hat man eh gewonnen.
Stimmt auch.
Besonders wenn man in der CDU ist oder wenn man Anwalt ist. Das war so die Konnotation, Anwälte brauchen keinen Doktor, wenn sie einen Freiherr haben. Was ich ja witzig fand, weil ich natürlich an Gravenreuth denken musste. Aber so diese Idee, dass der Doktor eigentlich überhaupt nicht irgendwie inhaltlich irgendwas aussagt, sondern nur dazu da ist, quasi den Klassenunterschied hervorzuarbeiten und zu sagen, ich bin hier der Freiherr, vielleicht nicht im Sinne von ich bin geadelt, aber im Sinne von ich habe etwas erarbeitet, ich bin was Besseres. Genau. Das ist ein Schmuck. Ja, nee, aber das finde ich interessant, weil das bringt uns nämlich auch zu der Frage, warum jetzt in der CDU das so ein Gemurmel gibt gerade. Also man kann ja sehen, das ist nicht nur die SPD, die sich da aufregt, weil sie halt in einer Opposition ist, sondern es gibt auch echt Stunkrade unter den Konservativen, die auch sehr unzufrieden damit sind, wie das gehandelt wird.
Also in einem geradezu erstaunlichen Maße. Ich glaube der Grund ist, dass da das Gefühl entstanden ist, dass der Guttenberg mit diesem Plagiat und dann nicht zurücktreten den Grundkonsens aufgekündigt hat, dass es Bildung und Ehrlichkeit so die Grundpfeiler dessen sind, mit denen man dieses Land irgendwie noch aus der Scheiße ziehen kann.
Was ja auch ein Lacher ist, aber es ist halt die Zähne.
Na ja, ich meine, aber auch interessanterweise, wenn du zum Beispiel die Sarazien-Debatte anguckst, am Ende lief dir darauf hinaus, wie sie versucht haben, diese Thesen von denen hinzudrehen, ja, wir brauchen mehr Bildung für diese Leute. Dieses Bildung war noch der letzte Konsens, auf dem man sich geeinigt hat, dass Bildung ist das, wo keiner darüber diskutiert, dass es wichtig und gut ist. Aber so offen und so dermaßen dreist, hat diesen Konsens aufgewendigt. Das hat einige Leute sehr wütend gemacht, auch Leute, von denen ich es nicht erwartet habe. Auch die sehr konservative Leute, die also nicht...
Die Atlantikbrücke zum Beispiel ist gerade dabei, sich darüber zu spalten. Das ist ja ausgesprochen cool.
Da muss man vielleicht noch mal erklären, was die Atlantikbrücke ist, Kurz.
Nein, du hast die Bühne.
Die Atlantikbrücke ist so eine hinter der Bühne Lobbyverein für deutsch-amerikanische Freundschaft.
Schon auch ein offizieller Verein.
Ja, aber der zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass du nur Mitglied wirst, wenn zwei andere Mitglieder für dich wirken und du eingeladen wirst. Also du kannst nicht einfach eintreten.
Das ist irgendwie so ähnlich wie im Club, oder?
Ja, genau. Und die sind halt der deutsch-amerikanischen Freundschaft verbunden. Und das ist halt ein sehr illustrer Club. Also da sind halt von einst als links eingeschätzten Spiegelredakteuren bis zu irgendwie allen möglichen...
Das muss doch mal lange her sein.
Und der Chef heißt Friedrich Merz derzeit.
Genau, konservativen, richtig konservativen, da findet man so einmal alles. Und die...
Das ist der Club der buscharsch-krieger, die gesagt haben, der Krieg ist gut, wir müssen da mitmachen, die uns nach Afghanistan getrieben haben.
Wo wir... Was verteidigen wir da nochmal?
Seine Doktorarbeit.
Die Opienpreise und seine Doktorarbeit.
Das war einst der Plakate heute auf der Demo der Schilder.
Der Doktortitel wird am hindukusch verteidigt.
Ja, wo ich auch sagen muss, da kann ich auch nur zu aufrufen.
Was war der eigentliche Spruch von dem Stroke? Ach, unsere Sicherheit wird am hindukusch verteidigt. Oder?
Freiheit, Demokratie, Grundrechte ist doch egal. Unsere Werte, unsere christlichen Werte. Also ich sehe das ja ein bisschen anders. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Bildung sozusagen der Konsens ist, sondern ich glaube, das ist der amerikanische Traum, der da verkauft wird. Dass man sagt, wir investieren in die Bildung, damit die Leute die illusion haben, sie könnten den Klassenunterschied überwinden. Denn eigentlich, was die CDU betreibt, ist ja Klassenkampf. Sie sehen sich als die, wir haben es ja in der letzten Sendung schon thematisiert, Arbeitgeber, wo man sagen würde, die Fabrikbesitzer, die Kapitalisten und sie versuchen, sich gegen die anderen, eben die Arbeitnehmer, die Bittsteller, den Pöbel zu verteidigen. Und das geht natürlich nur oder am besten, wenn man das minimiert, dass sie sich wehren und das geht, indem man ihnen die illusion gibt, dass sie eine Chance haben, aufzusteigen. Und das ging halt früher über die Heirat von Leuten aus einer anderen Klasse. Und heute ist es eben diese Idee, dass du, wenn du nur genug Bildung hast, kannst du aus dir machen, was du willst. Und es gibt eben zwei Aspekte daran.
Das war nicht Teil des amerikanischen Traumes. Die Rockefeller-Story ist frei von Bildung, sondern sie ist eher Hard Work.
Ja, aber das kannst du ja in Deutschland nicht verkaufen.
Nee, aber insofern ist es schon so, dass das eigentlich eher der deutsche Traum ist.
Richtig, der immer europäische.
Der europäische, ja. Also es ist halt eigentlich die Variante des amerikanischen Traums ist ja hier, wenn du irgendwie hart arbeitest, damit du irgendwie ordentliche Bildung kriegst. Wenn du eine gute ausbildung hast, dann steht die Welt offen. Das ist irgendwie so der Traum, der hier verkauft wird. Und zumindest zu einem kleinen Stück ist der ja auch wahr.
Na, aber es geht halt nicht so, was ich sage, es geht nicht so um den sozialistischen Grundgedanken von wegen irgendwie Bildung für alle. Da ist nichts Humanitäres dran, sondern es geht darum, hier ist deine Karriere, Geld machen, du kannst dich von dem Pöbel abgrenzen, du kannst besser sein als deine Eltern. Das ist ja auch, was alle Eltern, ihre Kinder wollen. Das ist im Grunde der amerikanische Traum, oder nennen wir es der deutsche Traum. Und das funktioniert eben nur, wenn man sowas wie Bildung anbietet. Und das ist ja an sich unumstritten, vor allem, weil sich eben die höheren Schichten auch über ihre Bildung definieren. Also diese, wir haben ja schon alle möglichen Titel nicht mehr. Das ist immer ganz witzig, wenn man nach Österreich geguckt hat.
So ein Geheimrat und sowas.
Ja, und Rittmeister. Also die haben super geile Videos gehabt. Die sind leider vor ein paar Jahren in einer Strafung zum Opfer gefallen. Aber diese Idee, sich über seine Errungenschaften und Titel zu definieren als was Besseres als der Rest, das ist durchaus eine alte Idee. Und die sieht man auch heute noch sehr verbreitet in gerade Parteien wie FDP und CDU, wo fast nur irgendwelche Doktoren und Lehrer, die sich sowieso für was Besseres halten, sind ja alle Lehrer und Juristen.
Also 55 für die Unionsfraktionen sind Doktoren. Also natürlich abzüglich Gutenberg.
Jetzt heißt es eine Quote von einem Sechstel oder so.
Damit sind sie die Fraktion mit den meisten promovierten.
Na gut, wir haben halt Lehrer und Juristen, und die definieren sich eben ganz gerne auch darüber, was sie in ihrer Bildung erreicht haben. Und wenn jetzt jemand wie der Gutenberg kommt und einfach mit einem Fake-Doktor-Titel durchkommt, dann entwertet das eben die Leistung aller anderen. Und deswegen sind die gerade echt unzufrieden mit dem Gutenberg. Also das ist nicht nur eine Sache, die wir jetzt von außen an die herantragen.
Also das Feedback, was ich so bekomme von Leuten, mit denen ich es nicht mitgerechnet habe, und auch das Feedback, was wir auf der Straße bekommen haben heute.
Das können wir vielleicht kurz erzählen. Erzähl doch mal jeder sein Beispiel.
Wir sind ja mit den Plakaten durch die Gegend gezogen zur Demonstration. Und das Feedback, was wir auf der Straße bekommen haben, war durchbekommen positiv. Und das waren halt in der Regel eher ältere, eher so ein bisschen besser gekleidete Leute.
Gut situierte.
Gut situierte Leute. Und ich hab keinen einzigen negativen Kommentar heute gehört auf der ganzen Strecke.
Das lag vielleicht aber auch daran, dass wir diese Doktor der Herzensschild dabei hatten.
Du meinst, haben die Leute viel verstanden und gedacht, wir machen Werbung für all die Sendungen?
Na ja, ich weiß nicht, ob die Ironie bei jedem ankam.
Also ich bin ja angehalten worden auf der Straße, auf dem Rückweg. Ob wir jetzt auf dem Rückweg sein oder ob die Demo noch stattfindet, das heißt, ich glaube, wenn wir das logistisch ein bisschen mehr Vorlauf gehabt hätten.
Ja gut, also jetzt die 48-Stunden-Mobilisierungsfrist war ein bisschen knapp, aber ich denke mal, wenn es nächste Wochenende weitergeht, dann werden da deutlich mehr Leute sein.
Ja, und die Sache mit den Schuhen hat hervorragend geklappt, darf man sagen. Das war prima.
muss man auch so sagen.
Mich hat ein bisschen gewundert, dass im Vorfeld ein bisschen Streit darum, vor allen Dingen in den Blogs und auch in deinem Blog bei den Kommentaren war, dass man diese Schuhsymbolik nicht mehr nutzen dürfte. Ich denke, dass da Leute nicht verstanden haben, wo es ursprünglich mal herkommt. Und jetzt sehr auf diese Tunesien und Ägypten-Sache beziehen. Vielleicht auch weil das Bild beim Demo-Aufruf vom Tarierplatz war.
Das hat ja auch einen Hintergrund, wie er daherkommt.
Eben, aber den wissen kennen die Leute nicht mehr.
Ich bin ja auch gefragt worden von so einem Typ, ich weiß nicht, dass es einen Journalisten mit Merz und einem Blog dabei gab, und er hat sich da Notizen gemacht. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, für wen der da war. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Aber wahrscheinlich der Coverbeamte von der DPA oder so was weiß ich. Jedenfalls wollte der halt aufwissen, was er mit den Schuhen auf sich hat. Der Hintergrund ist der, dass im arabischen Raum, wo jetzt die ganzen Vorbilddemonstrationen laufen und Revolution, da ist es eben eine sehr große Beleidigung, wenn man jemandem seine Schuhsohle zeigt, weil traditionell da trafen die sich in ihren Zelten und da klebt noch Kamilscheiße dran und das ist eben eine echt große Beleidigung im Kulturraum.
Also das ist eher so eine Form von, wir zeigen Verachtung und Disrespekt.
Das ist, was wir hier mit dem erhobenen Mittelfinger machen.
Oh, weiß nicht, ob das vergleichbar ist. Wir müssen aber nicht die Schmähungen und die Symbolik der Schmähungen heute hier durch exerzieren.
Nein, aber es ist jedenfalls ein Symbol der Unzufriedenheit. Drücken wir es mal so aus. Das ist keine...
Was ich persönlich noch sehr schön finde, ist, dass es hier ein inverses Doppelzitat aus Wake the Dog ist.
Ein inverses Doppelzitat, genau.
Also für alle, die es noch nicht gesehen haben, obwohl wir es nun schon mehrfach nachdrücklich empfohlen haben, guckt euch endlich Wake the Dog an. Und wer es noch nicht getan hat, dann tut es heute. Es ist irgendwie definitiv wichtige Bildung. Da gibt es dann auch eine sehr schöne Szene mit Schuhen. Dann werdet ihr verstehen, was wir meinen. Und nein, wir werden es jetzt nicht erklären, damit ihr endlich diesen Film guckt.
Schön war noch, dass das Verteidigungsministerium diesen wunderbaren spitzen Zaun hatte, wo man die Schuhe noch so ranstecken konnte.
Und mit einem Schild dahinter, Vorsicht meditärischer Sicherheitsbereich, Vorsicht schusswaffengebrauch.
Das passte prima, ich hab so ein Panoramafoto genommen, wo man oben die Schuhe sah, dann den Zaun und dahinter den schusswaffengebrauch.
Wir wollten ja eigentlich heute ein bisschen über Bildung und Plattlerkommandos reden.
Na gut, die driften manchmal so ein bisschen ab. Aber abdriften ist in dieser Saison vollkommen allopft.
Ich bekenne mich, ich bin Hörer dieses Podcasts.
Na dann kennst du uns noch.
Aber ich will mich hier nicht unnötig anschleimen.
Nein, du begleitest das kritisch selbstverständlich.
Auch ein Kritiker. Ja, also zurück zum Plagiat. Du hast es ja in deinen Seminararbeiten und was immer du so betreust bei deinen Studenten, auch häufiger, dass die einfach kopieren. Was sind denn so die häufigsten Plagiatsformen?
Ich hab eigentlich, also ich war jetzt ja so sechs Jahre an der Humboldt-Uni hier und hab eigentlich schon seit vier, fünf Jahren das Problem regelmäßig auf den Tisch.
Du hast schon alle gesehen.
Ja, also ich hab auch, es gibt ja, man kann ja Plagiate noch klassifizieren nach der Art, wie plagiert wurde. Und ich hab eigentlich alle schon mal gesehen. Also typisch ist ja so, richtig so Copy und Paste, ohne viel Änderung. Dann die Art, wie die jetzt Gutenberg gemacht hat, dass man also kopiert und leichte Änderungen vornimmt, dass man mal einen Verb ändert oder mal einen Halbsatz wegkürzt oder ran schreibt. Dann gibt's noch die Übersetzungsplagiat. Eigentlich auch immer nicht allzu schwer zu finden, weil in der Regel da so die Fußnoten mit kopiert werden. Oder auch Begriffe, die in der übersetzten Sprache und in der deutschen Sprache gleich sind.
Und der Satzbau ist auch immer so ein bisschen komisch, wenn es aus dem Englischen übersetzt wird.
Ja, man merkt halt oft, dass das dann meist ein bisschen holprig ist. Das ist sowieso der beste Anhaltspunkt, ein Plagat zu finden, nämlich die Systembrüche.
Dass der inhaltliche fluss nicht mehr gegeben ist?
Also in der Regel dauert es exakt 40 Sekunden, du liest einen Text und weißt, das hat er nicht geschrieben. Man kann die Menschen einschätzen, du kennst sie ja aus dem Seminar. Dann gibt es aber noch die Schüttelplagiate, wo sie sich wirklich viel Mühe machen, zwar auch immer noch Rechtschreibfehler übernehmen, aber so richtig Halbsatz-Aneinandersetzungen. Und so gibt es auch. Und dann Gutenberg hat so eine Kombination, denn er hat nicht eine Quelle plagiert, sondern viele. Und das ist auch noch relativ häufig.
Was ich bei Gutenberg interessant fand, ist, dass er bei vielen Plagiatsstellen, die die Methode verwendet hat, dass er die Quelle angegeben hat, aber nicht alle Zitate aus dieser Quelle markiert. Dass er offensichtlich schon bewusst versucht hat, einfach diesen, ach, ich hab ja irgendwie ein Fehlerchen gemacht, diese Entschuldigung zu ermöglichen. Indem er einfach zwei, drei Sätze aus der Quelle zitiert und hat dann noch größere Stücke kopiert, ohne sie zu markieren.
Unterschiedlich, ich hab also bestimmt nicht alle...
Das ist ja ein Trick, den die Leute benutzen, um sich hinterher rausgehen zu können, oder?
Ja, das kann man in diesem guten Plug-Wiki ja auch toll sehen, aber er hat das offenbar zumindest so wie ich überblicke, ich hab bestimmt nicht alle Beispiele lesen, aber eine ganze Menge. Da hat er nur die Quellen auch tatsächlich in den Fuß nun angegeben, die so ein bisschen, wie soll ich mal sagen...
Offiziös sind so?
Äh, ja.
Also nicht diese Minararbeit.
Genau, diese Minararbeit.
Also deswegen, wenn er von der US-Botschaft kopiert, das steht da nicht drin.
Ganz genau. Also die Wissenschaftlichkeit noch so ein bisschen simulieren. Das ist ja auch ganz günstig, zum später rausreden, wenn man ja wenigstens überhaupt den Autor nimmt, von dem man dann vielleicht mal für ein Abseits oder zwei Seiten...
Dass er die Entschuldigung schon vorbaut, dass er dann sagt, ok Entschuldigung, habe ich nur vergessen zu markieren. Aber klar, so eine Erstsemester-Seminararbeit, die gibt man natürlich nicht als Quelle in seiner Doktorarbeit an.
Richtig, also er hat natürlich nur da angegeben, wozu diese Wissenschaftlichkeit simuliert.
Moment, aber dass wir richtig verstehen, nicht mal seine Plagiatsart war er neu.
Es gibt nur eine bestimmte Anzahl von Möglichkeiten, wie man Text klauen kann. Er hat ja auch Übersetzungsplagiate drin. Das bietet sich ja auch an.
Man kann es sozusagen auch als Schulungsmittel für Plagiatsarten verwenden.
Ja, man kann da eine Menge dran lernen. Zum einen, weil er ja Stücke ganz unverändert übernimmt, inklusive der Rechtschreibfehler oder manche auch inklusive der Quellen. Dann hat er wieder so ein bisschen, dass er mal einen Verb ändert oder mal einen Halbsatz weglässt oder mal eine Jahreszahl konkretisiert oder so. Dann hat er die Übersetzungsplagiate. Man kann da eigentlich prima, habe ich auch gemacht, ich kenne diese Semester in der Uni, ein Seminar für die jüngeren Studenten zum wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten, wo wir also versuchen, ihnen beizubringen, wie man eigentlich wissenschaftlich arbeitet. Denn viele wissen nicht, dass sie in die Uni kommen. Die haben keine Ahnung, was das eigentlich soll. Gerade bei den Informatikern, weil die glauben, die lernen da Programmieren. Natürlich lernen sie das nicht. Dann sind wir da zu Akademikern gemacht. Das ist ja was wir da tun, da geht es in der Fachhochschule. Und lustigerweise kam diese Pragerzibatte direkt vor dem allerletzten Termin, also vor Semesterenden. Und wir haben natürlich das letzte Mal darüber gesprochen. Dann haben die also ein Semester gelernt, wie man zitiert, wie man Quellen angibt, was Pseudowissenschaft ist, wie man irgendwie über die eigene Arbeit als Wissenschaftler reflektiert. Und dann kam die lustige Gutenberg-Debatte. Und war schon interessant, dass die natürlich sich auch alle sehr kritisch geäußert haben.
Also war es nicht völlig sinnlos, die Gutenberg-Arbeit. Er hat dem wissenschaftlichen Fortschritt einen Beitrag geleistet.
Ich würde mich hier nicht verteidigen.
Das ist ja durchaus eine interessante Frage, ist ja eben, warum ist es denn so schlimm? Also was ist denn eigentlich das Schlimme am Plagiate? Du sollst vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen drüber reden.
Es hat ja mehrere Ebenen. Das eine ist, also wenn man mal angenommen ist für normale kleine Seminararbeit. Wir haben eine Runde von, weiß ich nicht, 12 Studenten. Alle geben irgendetwas ab. Es wird vielleicht sogar bewertet. Also man kriegt ja heute vierfach Noten in der Uni. Ist ja nicht nur ein Schein oder Nicht-Schein. Man ist natürlich, wenn zwei davon Plagiat abgeben, verändert die Sicht auf die Qualität. Das ist erstmal eine Frage.
Meinst du jetzt allgemein oder nur für die beiden? Also wo warst du denn den ganzen Jahrgang gestern?
Klar, du bewertest ja, das ist ja bei klausuren auch nicht anders. In der Regel guckt man ja nach der Qualität der gesamten Menge der Studenten und so wird die auch in der Regel dann bewertet. Dass man halt mal guckt, wie gut sind die eigentlich, wie können die sich ausdrücken stilistisch, wie gehen die mit den Quellen um und so. Und so muss man natürlich immer überlegen, dass die anderen zehn, die keinen Plagiat abgegeben haben, natürlich doppelt benachteiligt sind.
Doppelt benachteiligt, wieso?
Na ja, sie werden vielleicht weil diejenigen, die plagiert haben, die guten Arbeiten kopiert haben, gut bewertet werden. Schlechter bewertet, weil sie sich immer an was anderes messen.
Weil sie relativ schlechter sind.
Wir hören mal oft die Fälle, dass sie zum Beispiel, wenn sie bei den Plattformen so eine Arbeit kaufen, dann steht die Bewertung ja schon dran. Du kannst ja eine hausarbeit suchen, die ist dann schon mit 1,3 oder 1,0 bewertet. Und entsprechend gibst du natürlich nichts ab oder du versuchst jedenfalls zu suchen, wenn man nicht gerade eine 4 gekriegt hat. Und davon änderts den Schnitt der Bewertung.
Das heißt, der schlaue Plagiator kopiert eine Arbeit auf seinem Notenschnitt. Dann spart er sich die Arbeit. Aber es gibt keinen ausrutscher in seinem Notenspiegel oder wie?
Es ist eigentlich ein bisschen schlauer, sich eine schlechtere Arbeit zu kopieren. Schon deshalb, weil man natürlich auch oft diejenigen, die plagieren, sind ja nicht so die Hellsten. Und das heißt, der Stil, wenn du dann merkst, eine tolle Arbeit irgendwie geschliffen formuliert mit einem super Fazit. Und dann guckst du den Studenten an und denkst, wait. Also es sind ja eben nicht die Hellsten. Es sind ja eben nicht die, die irgendwie eine wissenschaftliche Neugier haben oder gerne was lesen, was sie lernen wollen. Und dann auch diese Studere kommt von sich mühen und sich anstrengen. Das haben die ja nicht. Sondern die wollen ja möglichst ein 8,2 Semestern ihr Studium hinter sich haben und hatten möglichst wenig Arbeit. Und deshalb wäre für die eigentlich schlauer, nicht die 1,0 Arbeiten zu kopieren.
Ist es denn deine Erfahrung nach so, dass die die Motivation zum Plagieren ist, nur reine Arbeitsersparnis oder ist es tatsächlich auch einfach, dass sie zu doof sind und einfach die Anforderungen sich nicht erfüllen könnten?
Also die, die ich so, also ich zitiere ja alle, die bei mir ein Plagiat abgeben, auch nochmal zu mir hin. Also ich rede auch mit allen. Und ich hab ja über diese GI-Gruppe, also die Gruppe der Gesellschaft Informatik, wo wir zusammenarbeiten.
Was du mit der B machst.
Genau. Also will ich dir mal am vorne sagen. Die Gesellschaft Informatik hat eine eigene Gruppe für Ethik und Informatik. Und da sind wir halt ein paar Wissenschaftler, die sich seit ein paar Jahren, jetzt ungefähr sieben Jahre, glaube ich, so intensiv mit solchen Fragen befassen. Und darunter ist auch Deborah Weber-Wulf, die ja die sogenannte Plagg-Jatzli-Jägerin ist. Also die auch viele ihrer Fälle mir erzählt hat. Also das ist nicht nur meine eigene Erfahrung. Und mittlerweile gibt es sogar Bücher. Also darüber. Das schöne Buch von Volker Rieble ist nicht schlecht. Wo man ja so ein bisschen strukturiert mal erfahren kann, wo das Problem ist. Aber meine eigenen Studenten mir eigentlich sagen, wenn ich es erwische, ist an der Regel eher eine Überforderung. D.h. ich habe Studenten, die kommen an die Uni, die sind strukturell nicht in der Lage, einen eigenen Text zu schreiben, der auf 10, 12 Seiten Gedanken darlegt. Zu einem Thema, bei dem gehen ja in der Regel Vorgeber als Dozenten. Die können sich dazu nicht aussehen. Die stehen vor einem leeren Blatt oder vielmehr sitzen vor einem Open-Office-Bildschirm oder so. Und wissen nicht, was sie machen sollen. Denn sie haben noch niemals die Bibliothek betreten oder so, lesen sehr wenig Bücher und können sich stilistisch oft auch sowieso nur so ausdrücken, wie sie es aus Zeitungsartikeln nicht eben bester Qualität kennen. Also das ist ein richtiges, das ist ein strukturelles Problem, dass man Abiturienten, gerade vielleicht in den technischen Fächern, ich hab natürlich jetzt immer nur Informatiker, die überhaupt nicht vorbereitet sind, auf so ein selbstständige Texte verfassen und Gedanken darlegen. Vielleicht sogar noch stilistisch schön und dennoch nach wissenschaftlichen Standards. Die haben überhaupt keine Idee, wie das gehen soll. Und dann ist es natürlich total einfach, wenn du 180 Arbeiten zu dem Thema schon findest. Mal in den jüngeren, also jetzt die, was wir früher Grundstudien benannt haben, jetzt der Bachelor, hast du natürlich auch Themen, die haben jetzt natürlich schon 7000 Leute in hausarbeiten geschrieben. Aber wir haben natürlich in der Gruppe, also jetzt in der GI-Gruppe auch durchaus schon andere plagierte Doktorarbeiten. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass Gutenberg da der einzige ist, der es nur besonders dreist, der ja keine Konsequenzen zieht.
Das heißt also, dass der zumindest bei den Studenten ist, die überwiegende Mehrzahl tatsächlich inhaltlich überfordert von Anforderungen und plagiert, weil sie die geistige Leistung offentlich nicht erbringen könnte.
Ja, das ist mein Eindruck. Nicht alle, es gibt natürlich auch welche, die wirklich richtig fau sind. Also das gibt es auch auch, aber...
Also wir haben sozusagen ein Dummheitsplagiat und wir haben ein Faulheitsplagiat.
Ja, oder eine Kombination.
Und dann gibt es noch so eine Kombination davon.
Was macht ihr denn, wenn ihr so ein Plagiat erwischt? Du hast ja gesagt, du zitierst sie dann zu dir und redest mit denen. Hat das irgendwelche handfesten Konsequenzen? Irgendwie kriegen die dann den Schein nicht? Oder müssen die noch mal schreiben? Oder was passiert dann?
Also die meisten Unis in Deutschland haben keine konkreten Sanktionen. Denn anders als bei so Prüfungen, wenn du da halt betrügst, dann kriegst du noch fünf. Ist das ja bei diesen hausarbeiten, wofür du den Schein gibt, anders. Und weswegen ich jetzt schon seit längerer Zeit für meinen Studenten auch eine Erklärung auch für hausarbeiten will, selbst für zehn oder zwölf oder 15-seitige Arbeitende.
Also so eine Eigenständigkeit zu erklären.
Genau, denn sonst habe ich rechtlich eigentlich überhaupt keine richtige Handhabe. Ich kann eigentlich sanktionsmäßig wenig machen. Die Konkretture ist, ich bestell die mir erstmal ein. In der Regel wissen die sehr wohl, warum ich sie einbestellt habe. Siehst du schon, wenn sie an der Tür stehen? Also die wissen genau, weswegen ich Bescheid gesagt habe, ich brauche das nicht in der Mail schreiben. Und dann kriege ich die drei standard-ausreden. Nämlich? Ja, also entweder ist das so etwas wie, Oma ist gestorben oder kindkrank. Also dass sie so irgendetwas Persönliches vorschieben. Das ist aber immer nur der Anfang. Also wenn man mit ihnen weiter redet, dann sagen wir ja auch ein bisschen genauer, worum es geht. Der zweite ist, er hat die Anführungszeichen vergessen. Das kommt auch immer noch. Das ist immer sehr lustig. Also da haben sie natürlich nicht nur die Anführungszeichen vergessen, sondern auch die Fußnote und die Quelle vergessen. Und der dritte ist oft dann so ein bisschen so richtig dreif, also abstreiten, musstet ihn belegen. Das gibt es auch.
Ach das gibt es natürlich auch.
Das gibt es auch. Wobei der allergrößte Fall war, das war ja bei Gunther gauss noch.
Das ist interessant, insofern ist diese Typisierung der Plagiate hochspannend.
Der allergrößte Fall war mal, da sitz ich bei mir im Büro und lese eine Arbeit. Das ging da um Verschlüsselung. Ich habe ein Seminar angeboten zur Geschichte der Verschlüsselung. Ich lese zwei Sätze und denke, wait, das hast du selbst formuliert. Ich weiß es jetzt nicht. Ein Student, der hat mir meine eigene Arbeit selbst, also bei mir in meinem Seminar, eingereicht als seine hausarbeit. Mir ist erstmal die Kindeslade total auf den Schreibtisch geklappt.
Immerhin rechtschreibliche Normen.
Das ist ja auch eine Form von Dummheit und Dreistigkeit.
Die gehen davon aus, dass du nicht liest.
Genau, das zeigt, dass die Studenten wissen, dass nur ein Teil der Arbeit überhaupt gelesen wird. Also ich meine, so dumm, mir meine eigene Arbeit einzureichen. So dumm kann man eigentlich nicht sein.
Gibt es auch irgendwelche, die der Lore Ipsum einreichen?
Das ist mir noch nicht passiert. Also ich bestell natürlich schon fest, dass meine Studenten das sehr mögen, wenn ich ihnen auf Arbeiten Feedback gebe. Also wenn ich mich mit ihnen hinsetze, eine halbe Stunde oder 20 Minuten und mit ihnen durchgehe, war das Problem. Bei jüngeren Studenten ist das ja auch total sinnvoll, weil du willst ja, dass sie die wissenschaftliche Arbeit lernen. Du willst ihnen ja beibringen, warum ist diese Fußrote falsch und wie muss besser zitiert werden oder so. Das erfahren die oft nicht. Das liegt daran, dass tatsächlich die wenig Feedback bekommen.
Das ist ja auch nicht Aufgabe der Schule normalerweise, wissenschaftliche Arbeiten beizubringen. Naja, das ist ein Gedanke, um die da schreiben kannst.
Bei Gymnasium würde ich das einfach schon erwarten, weil einfach davon auszugehen ist, dass der größte Teil der Leute, die auf dem Gymnasium sind, studiert.
Ja, aber das steht nicht im Curriculum, warum nicht?
Hattest du es gelernt im Gymnasium?
Nee, ich hab es nicht gelernt. Ich weiß nur, dass bei mir, als ich angefangen habe zu studieren, gab es erstens ein zweites Semester, eine verpflichtende Veranstaltung technik-wissenschaftlichen Arbeitens. Und wenn du den Schein nicht hattest, konntest du einfach schlicht nicht weiter studieren.
Ja, das gab es früher sehr häufig. Das ist aber in vielen Wissenschaften nicht mehr der Fall. Also wir haben das jetzt erstmalig gemacht, freiwillig auch. War auch gut besucht, das Seminar. Aber das gibt es nicht mehr strukturell. Ist oft weggefallen.
Nee, also es war so, dass sie dir gesagt haben, wenn du diesen Schein nicht hast, brauchst du gar nicht erst überlegen, ob du den Grundstuhl des abschlusses kriegst. Das passiert einfach nicht.
Tja, Frank, du bist wohl nicht mehr der Jüngste. Schon lange her. Also das ist ja tatsächlich nicht mehr üblich.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Tja, also die Annahme, das macht immer...
So gut funktioniert. Du brauchst da Vorwände, um die Leute rauszuschmeißen.
Hm, das würde ich nicht unbedingt sagen.
Na, ich meine, wie viele Leute kommen denn durch bei der Uni?
Na, bei uns sind die Absolventenquoten sehr gering. Also bei 50 Prozent oder vielleicht in dem Dreh jedenfalls, weil die einfach zwischendurch arbeiten gehen und dann nicht weiter studieren.
Das ist ein Informatik spezifisches Problem.
Ja, also wir haben ganz viele, die die nicht bis zum Ende machen. Es gibt auch einen kleinen Prozentanteil, der sich schafft inhaltlich. Vor allen Dingen, die mathematischen Anforderungen zu heftig sind. Aber das ist kein Wissenschaftsproblem, sondern die sind einfach auch nicht willig, sich das anzueignen.
Du siehst schon, dass du eigentlich, wenn jemand dir eine plagierte Arbeit einreicht, dann ist das für dich schon eigentlich ein Indiz, dass er möglicherweise inhaltliche Probleme mit dem Studium hat.
Nicht unbedingt. Das muss ich mir dann immer erstmal ansehen, wenn er kommt. Also die erste ist übrigens, ich hab da eine starke emotionale Reaktion bei mir selber drauf. Also ich fühle mich...
Verarscht, ja?
Ja. Das geht auch nicht weg. Auch nicht, wenn mir das häufiger passiert. Mir passiert das hier öfter mal. Also ich fühle mich immer noch...
Persönlich angegriffen? Ja.
Das ist eine ganz komische Sache, weil ich mich ja natürlich dann, wenn ich mir die einbestehe, da ja irgendwie zusammenreißen muss.
Die nicht zusammenzuscheißen.
Ja, natürlich. Ich hatte auch mal einer, das kann ich mir noch mal erzählen, einer hat mich mal total ausgenockt. Die hatte mir ein dreistes Plagiat abgegeben, wo sie sogar noch die Sachen, wo sie rauskopiert hat. Das war sehr lustig, die waren sehr fehlerhaft und teilweise aus der Wikipedia kopiert. Also, hm, das fand ich sehr dreist. Aber die hat mich ausgenockt, indem sie nach exakt 20 Sekunden in meinem Büro anfing zu weinen. Da war ich natürlich, da war ich total hilflos. Da konnte ich sie nicht mehr anschreien. Das war sehr schwierig.
Oh, jetzt hast du aber den Trick verraten, wie man bei dir durchkommt.
Du, ich hab fast nur männliche Studenten und deswegen...
Ach, das passiert nicht, meinst du ja?
Also, ich hab noch nie einen der männlichen Studenten beim Büro heulen sehen. Außerdem höre ich zum 31. März auf und insofern wird sich der Trick...
Na dann kannst du ja jetzt aber richtig in die Vorhänge gehen.
Das kannst du aber auch nicht vom Leder ziehen. Ich hab da sowieso nie... Das sieht sich dann berghaltig. Ich hatte auch vorhin ein Riesenproblem, dass der Lehrkörper hat zu lange gebraucht, um darauf zu reagieren. Also, wenn ich heute jemanden habe, der Dozent ist oder im abschluss arbeitet oder sogar Promotionen abnimmt und wie der Doktorvater von dem Gutenberg, Professor Heberle, offenbar nicht in der Lage ist, eine simple Plagiarzprüfung zu machen, das hätte man ja bei den vielen Stellen sehr einfach machen können. Dann hätte ich natürlich auch schon von den Lehrkräften, die ja für ausgesprochen fragwürdig davor gehen. Wir sind doch nicht mehr irgendwie 1990. Das Netz ist jetzt irgendwie über zehn Jahre unter uns.
Also wie viel Aufwand macht sich denn so ein Doktorvater mit einer Arbeit? Das ist ja vielleicht auch eine Sache, die man nicht wieder einschätzen kann.
Das ist natürlich sehr unterschiedlich abhängig. Idealtypisch sollte es so sein, dass man a. schon anfangs als Doktorvater mit seinem Promomenten bespricht. Wie soll es losgehen? Dann schreibt man so ein Exposé oder zumindest ist man auch öfter mal in den Forschungskologien und bereitet so ein bisschen aus, wie man in den letzten Jahren vorangekommen ist und so weiter. Schon eine intensive Betreuung eigentlich. Praktisch ist es natürlich nicht immer so. Es gibt viele Doktoranden, die schreiben ganz viel allein, weil sie vielleicht wollen oder aber weil sie keine Betreuung bekommen. Aber wenn man einen Doktorvater hat, der so ein krasses, wie nennst du es, Monsterplagiert, nicht findet, dann finde ich das ein Teil der Schuld, nicht nur bei dem Betrüger, der Eingereichte zu suchen ist, sondern natürlich auch bei dem Doktorvater und auch bei dem Zweitgutachter. Die haben die beiden Tomaten auf den Augen.
Wie ist denn das konkret?
Es gibt einen Zweitgutachter?
Einen Drittgutachter sogar.
Einen Drittgutachter? Nein, bei Gutenberg war es wohl so, es gab einen Erst- und einen Zweitgutachter, aber es gibt natürlich auch noch eine Kommission.
Aber eigentlich gibt es doch bei normalerweise, bei Doktorarbeiten...
Zwei.
Zwei? Okay.
Ist das immer so Peer-Review-mäßig kostenlos, dass die das in ihrer Freizeit irgendwie ehrenamtlich machen sollen, oder kriegst du Geld als Gutachter?
Nein, du kriegst dafür kein Geld, aber natürlich bist du Teil der Professurentätigkeit und es kann ein gutes Renommee sein, wenn man sehr schöne Doktorarbeiten betreut.
Du brauchst ja deine wissenschaftliche DNA als Professor, baust ja eben auch über deine Doktoranden auf.
Vor allem, wer fährt jetzt denn bitte von der Haltung? Die Wissenschaft, du weißt ja schon.
Ich versuche, ich bin ein Hacker, ich versuche strukturell zu verstehen, wer da einen Anreiz hat, sich wie zu verhalten. Und die Schilderung, die ich gehört habe von Peer-Review, war, dass quasi die Verlage, also Peer-Review jetzt nicht für Doktorarbeiten, sondern für Publikation, dass die Verlage im Grunde ihre Einsendung per E-Mail oder damals noch ausgedruckt an die Professoren mailen. Und die haben dann auf ihrem Schreibtisch irgendwie so einen Berg von Dingern, die sie nie lesen können, weil sie schon zeitlich gar nicht dazu kommen und weil sie auch kein Geld dafür kriegen und weil auch im Grunde keine Renommee abfällt für die Peer-Reviewer von Doktor-Abekannten aus.
Das ist aber schon ein strukturelles Problem, was Fefe jetzt anspricht. Das stimmt schon. Also ich kenne das selber. Also ich habe schon Peer-Reviewed für die Informatik-Spektrum, also eine wissenschaftliche Zeitung, weil ich ja in meiner eigenen Situation ein Thema mache, was nicht so viele in Deutschland machen. Und so habe ich also einen Beitrag bekommen und sollte den Peer-Reviewed. Das ist tatsächlich eine kostenlose Leistung, die im Prinzip in meiner Freizeit mache. Natürlich ist es aber so, man muss immer denken, normalerweise hast du ein schweres Erkenntnisinteresse als Wissenschaftler, das treibt dich ja eigentlich an. Das kann schon mal ein bisschen nerven, vor allem wenn du was schlechtes bekommst, weil du musst ja nach dem Peer-Reviewed aufschreiben, was du über den Beitrag denkst.
Hast du irgendeinen Anreiz in die eine oder andere Richtung an der Stelle?
Nicht wirklich.
Also gibt es da so ein, irgendwie, das ist hier mein Kollege, über den schreibe ich nichts schlechtes, weil das kommt zurück oder so?
Es ist ja unterschiedlich. Ich kann ja einen Blind, also Double-Blind oder Blind Peer. Manchmal musst du ja nicht wissen.
Ist das in der Praxis so?
Nee, also so wie ich es kenne, wusste ich in der Regel, wer der Autor ist. Aber der Autor weiß nicht, wer die Gutachter sind.
Na, das hilft ja auch nicht. Da musst du ja andersrum sein.
Na, du schreibst vielleicht ein bisschen offener deine Meinung, wenn du weißt, dass derjenige, der das Gutachten bekommt, nicht weiß, dass du es bist. Weil Wissenschaft ist sehr klein und die Netzwerke kommen.
Ja, eben, aber stell dir vor, du bist der Gutachter und du kennst den Typ und du weißt, oh, das ist eine Flasche, dann bist du doch voreingenommen.
Für mich war das schon interessant zu sehen, wer dich geschrieben hat, weil du natürlich einen Text anders liest, wenn du weißt, was man macht.
Ja, eben, aber das ist doch gerade vermeiden mit so einem Peer Review, dass irgendwie der Typ bewertet wird.
Ich meine, gerade zum Beispiel unter dem Gesichtspunkt des Plagiats entdecken, ist es extrem wichtig zu wissen, wer es eigentlich ist, damit du zum Beispiel einen eigenen Plagiat entdecken kannst. Also, dass er halt einfach so ein Arbeiten halt irgendwie in leichter Modifikation fünfmal einreicht.
Na, aber das ist doch üblich nach dem.
Das ist schon deshalb üblich, weil viele gerade von jungen Wissenschaftlern verlangen, dass sie in einer bestimmten Zeit bestimmte Veröffentlichungen haben. Also der Druck kommt ja auch noch dazu. Gerade wenn du irgendwie so frisch angefangen hast, und sollst du irgendwie zehn Publikationen im Jahr oder so was nachweisen, dann schickst du natürlich irgendwie den Krempel hin. Ich hab das nie getan, ich bin aber stolz, was ich nicht musste. Aber ich kenne von den wissenschaftlichen Mitarbeitern eine Menge, die da ganz viel Druck haben von ihren Professoren, damit die Veröffentlichungslisten lang sind.
Und ist das nur für eine wissenschaftliche Karriere anstrebt, oder hat das auch mit deinem normalen Titel zu tun? Und wenn du danach irgendwie, sagen wir, gerüstfertig bist?
Nee, das ist schon eher für die Leute, die in der Akademie ja bleiben wollen. Also für die Doktorarbeit musst du nicht unbedingt eine Veröffentlichungsliste abgeben. Also du musst halt einfach eine gute Arbeit schreiben.
Also wir haben ja über den Doktorvater gemerkt, da gab es ja noch diese andere Geschichte, dass rausgekommen ist, dass das Familienvermögen der Gutenbergs, der Uni Bayreuth großzügig Spenden hat zukommen lassen.
Also sie haben es über die Rhön-Klinik gemacht.
Über die Rhön-Klinik, ja. Aber lustigerweise gehört die zur juristischen Fakultät. Es gibt da so eine...
Ja, es gibt da so eine Quersubventionierung.
Ja, aber ich meine, das fand ich ja irgendwie doch sehr witzig. Was hat denn ein Juror mit der Rhön-Klinik zu tun?
Na ja, Medizin gibt es mittlerweile eine Menge juristische Themen.
Weil die Harzler alle verklagt werden wegen fusch oder was? Das lässt ja tief blicken, wenn die gleich ihre Juristen in derselben Abteilung ausbilden.
Wo ich aber gerne noch mal hinwollte, da waren wir vorhin so ein bisschen abgebogen, ist diese Frage, wie entdeckt man denn Plagiate ganz praktisch? Und denkst du denn, dass es tatsächlich mit der Digitalisierung der Publikation, gerade in der Wissenschaft und auch im Studienalltag, ist ja zum einen Plagiate einfacher geworden, weil du Sachen als Copy-Paste-Vorlage hast. Die Hürde ist niedrig, du musst nicht mehr aus dem Buch abtippen. Zum anderen aber ist natürlich eigentlich auch für dich het einfacher geworden, weil du ja natürlich mit irgendwie halbautomatischen Methoden sehr viel einfacher detektieren kannst, wo Inhalte herkommen.
Natürlich.
Also siehst du, dass irgendjemand in diesem Arms Race am Ende den gewinnen wird?
Naja, du hast natürlich als Dozent, du hast als Erstes den Vorteil, dass du dich in der Regel in dem Feld...
Also du kennst die Arbeiten in dem Feld.
Genau, also zumindest sollte man das annehmen. Also du hast natürlich Informationsvorsprung. Natürlich gibt es auch mal Sachen, wo das schwierig ist. Also wenn wir zum Beispiel zu aktueller Technik besprechen im Seminar, kommt das schon mal vor, dass du dich auch, dass du selber, wenn der Student ziemlich gut ist oder so, oder sehr viel recherchiert hättest, du selber noch mal nachschlagen musst und so. Das kommt jetzt nicht so, dass man immer der Vollguru ist. Aber in der Regel hat man halt einen viel besseren Überblick über das Thema. Insofern ist natürlich in der Klappseite die Arbeit in der Regel erstmal hinten auf und guckst dir die Quellen an. Man fängt ja nicht vorne an zu lesen, sondern meistens erstmal vor uns rausgegangen, dann hast du schon erstmal einen ziemlich guten Überblick. Und da merkt man natürlich schon gleich immer, wenn mir ein Student für eine 12 Seiten Arbeit irgendwie so achticke Bücher angeben, dann sinierst du schon mal.
Die hat er auch notiert nicht gelesen, weil der Aufwand zu groß wäre.
Genau, andersrum genau. Wenn er dir irgendwie acht Wikipedia-Links als Quellen angeben, dann brauchst du dir nicht erst lesen, dann kann er gleich wieder überarbeiten, was sowieso über die Hälfte tun müssen.
Ernsthaft?
Ja.
Also du hast die Hälfte der Arbeiten mit?
Ja, jetzt die Hälfte der Arbeiten müssen überarbeiten.
Gibst du zurück wegen übermäßigen Wikipedia-Genoss?
Nein, sehr unterschiedliche Gründe. Das ist so was wie gar keine Quellen angegeben, keinen Bezug zu den Quellen. Also das war eine Quellenliste, aber es ist nirgendwo Bezug genommen. Rechtschirmung und Grammatik, die nicht akzeptabel ist. Da gibt es dann zu viele Sachen. Manche haben aber auch gar keine Ahnung, wie man das strukturell aufbaut. Da fehlt ja eine Gliederung, da gibt es keine Einleitung. Das ist ganz schlimm.
Okay, das heißt also am Ende ist es aber schon so, dass du, wenn, andersrum gefragt, helfen dir denn technologische Mittel dabei? Also benutzt du Software?
Ja, ich selber benutze keine Software. Aber ich kenne natürlich diese Tests. Also Turnitin zum Beispiel ist eine ziemlich bekannte, Plagiarism-Finder, da gibt es eine ganze Menge. Die haben aber alle nur so unterdurchschnittliche Bewertungen erfahren.
Aber eigentlich sollte das doch nicht so schwer sein.
Also ich habe meistens sehr lang.
Ja, aber Debbie macht da immer Tests und zerreißt die alle. Also mit Nachstrich und Fangen.
Aber es kann doch eigentlich nicht so schwer sein, sollte man doch so denken.
Ja, aber guck mal, die Leute, die sowas wissen, die arbeiten am Ende für Google und nicht für so einen Plagiats-Futzi.
Na, ich finde doch das nah. Du musst doch keine Ernstpunkte haben.
Also wenn du weißt, was du tust, dann machst du doch keine Plagiats-Finder-Software, sondern dann willst du Geld verdienen.
Obwohl, Google könnte das eigentlich tatsächlich tun, ne? Also ich meine, Google könnte diesen Markt komplett sofort unmittelbar ausräuchern.
Google würde viel mehr Geld machen, wenn sie Plagiate ermöglicht, anstatt sie zu finden. Natürlich.
Ich musste immer daran denken, dass sie irgendwann angefangen haben, bestimmte Strings zu sperren, als es so am Anfang, so vor fünf oder sechs Jahren, um die IT-Security ging. Dass Google bestimmte Verbindungen, könnt ihr euch noch erinnern?
Wo sie automatisiertes Suchen nach Vulnerabilities in Webservern sperren wollten.
Die Frage ist, wie weit man das übertragen könnte auf so gefährliche, oft plagierte Arbeiten, die dauert irgendwo eingerechnet.
Okay, aber hast du denn schon mal durch so ein Plagiat eine Arbeit in einem Feld gefunden, die du noch nicht kanntest, die du interessant fandest?
Ist mir auch schon passiert, also bei Übersetzungsplagiaten. Wenn du manchmal so arbeiten hast, meistens ist es ja ein englischsprachiger Raum, bei anderen Sprachen habe ich natürlich ein riesen Problem.
Das ist ja nicht so richtig eine Chance.
Klar, weil du einfach, da kannst du natürlich jetzt irgendwie Google Translate benutzen, aber du kannst auch finden, zum Beispiel anhand der Fußnoten, wenn jemand dazu übernimmt oder auch Begriffe, die eben nicht übersetzt werden, wenn du sie findest. Aber manchmal entdeckst du da interessante Arbeiten, weil die meisten der Plagierenden nehmen sich ja nicht eben die schlechtesten. Und daher gerade zum angloamerikanischen Raum erfindet man manchmal noch Sachen, sehr interessant.
Und wie ist das? Gibt es ja nun solche Seiten in die hausarbeiten, die halt kommerziell Zugriff auf solche Arbeiten bieten?
Auch da hat man eigentlich wenig Mühe, da man eigentlich ja nur dasselbe tut, was die Studenten auch machen.
Ach, den Keyword suchen.
Genau. Und so findest du das nicht schwer. Und du hast ja auch immer noch diese menschliche Komponente, die die Maschine nicht abnimmt, nämlich über einige Jahre entwickelt dir für dafür, wie sich ein Plagiat anfühlt.
Das ist einfach die Sprachstiliste.
Ja, das sind auch Brüche. Inhaltliche Brüche. Sprachlich vor allem. Ja, genau. Dann fängt ein neuer Absatz an und plötzlich ist es ein ganz anderer duktus. Und dann merkst du natürlich auch, dann hast du zum Beispiel mal eine ganze Seite, wo du wunderbare Gedanken hast, wo du einfach merkst, da hat sich jemand total Mühe gemacht, um dir was dazulegen und davor und dahinter ist Plebs. Dann merkst du natürlich sofort, wo der Hase ist. Oder dass du eine Seite hast und hast acht Fuß.
Jetzt geht der Klassenkampf ja aber auch los, ja? Ja, Plebs. Der Pöbel.
Die Knoblauchfresse.
Das war jetzt auch gar nicht so despektiv.
Das war jetzt nicht abwirten gemeint. Wir meinen den gutartigen Pöbel.
Guck, wenn du in die Uni kommst, du willst halt was lernen, das ist ja auch okay. Du kommst halt nicht hin und wie als der große Belletrist und Top-Akademiker, du willst was lernen. Und so sollten die Arbeiten doch irgendwie sein, wenn du da so eine geschliffene, mit Fachbegriffen gespickte hausarbeit hast, dann denkst du so, ah ja, yeah right.
Sag mal, würdest du insgesamt sagen, dass Plagiatserkennung funktioniert? Oder bist du da praktisch die Speerspitze und bei dir haben es die Leute besonders schwer und überall sonst kann man bescheißen, bis der Arzt kommt?
Also meine Erinnerung ist schon, dass das auf vierfach durchgeht. Also, dass viele damit Erfolg haben, was ein riesen Problem ist. Weil dein Chef könnte mal jemand sein, der eigentlich niemals akademische Weinen irgendwie erlangt hat, sondern eben so ein Durchmogler ist und später gibt er dir die Befehle. Also das ist ja auch so ein strukturelles Problem, dass natürlich die, die damit durchkommen, die heimsen sich ja diese in Deutschland eben sehr wichtige Titel- und Qualifikationsliste in ihrer Vita ein. Das ist ja ein riesen Problem eigentlich, wenn man dem ja vertraut in Deutschland.
Das ist halt eigentlich der zweite, neben der Ungerechtigkeit bei der Beurteilung, ist ja diese Erlangung von akademischen Geraden, die eigentlich nicht gerechtfertigt werden, ja das ist der zweite große Problem.
Naja, diese Ihren Doktoren sind ja auch nicht gerechtfertigt.
Nee, aber da steht halt ein HC dran, da weißt du, was du davon zu halten hast. Also das ist halt offensichtlich.
Es gibt eigentlich noch einen dritten Punkt, den man nicht...
Warte mal, lass uns erst mal kurz bei dem verweilen, nämlich diesem Ungerechtfertigte-Tragen von akademischen Ihren oder auch abschluss von Studien. Also das passiert ja auch nicht so selten bei Magisterarbeiten oder ähnlichen Dingen. Da ist es ja so, dass die Leute ja häufig kann alle unrechtsbewusstsein haben. Also mir ist es mal beging, ich hatte mal Kenntnis von so einem Fall, wo sich jemand seinen Doktor de facto gekauft hat über einen Ghostwriter. Also der hatte halt einen Großvater beauftragt, der hat ihm den Doktor geschrieben. Ist eben gerade so durch die Verteidigung gerutscht, weil er halt irgendwie echt, also die mögliche Verteidigung, weil er halt wirklich, also er hätte einfach keinen Doktor verdient.
musst du aber auch nicht überall machen, also kannst du dir auch noch, wenn er dir die auch anruft.
Ja, nee, in dem Fall war es so und war halt aber auch so, dass der...
Auch war auch keine Ahnung, oder wie?
War ganz objektiv so, dass der ausgenutzt hat, dass einer seiner Doktorväter komplett überlastet war und der andere, den hat das eigentlich nicht interessiert. Also das war halt, er hat das so social engineeringmäßig ganz gut hinbekommen. Und es war aber ganz offensichtlich, dass er das nicht verdient hätte. Und dem ist dann, der ist erwischt worden. lustige Geschichte, weil er versucht hat, die Kosten für diesen Großdreiter von der Steuer abzusetzen. Nein!
Oh, dass er auch ein Darwin-Award wird, oder?
Genau.
Und das war halt so. Dadurch ließ ich das irgendwie nicht mehr geheim halten.
Aber das ist irgendwie wie immer im Leben, wenn wir intelligente Kriminelle hätten, wir wären verloren.
Ja, vermutlich.
Einglückt, dass die alle so blöde sind.
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass die alle blöde sind. Ich glaube, wenn du smart genug bist, hast du es gar nicht so schwer, dir das Studium komplett durchzumugeln. Also wenn du mal angenommen hast, du hast ja nicht die Kohle für...
Aber du musst das nicht, wenn du smart bist, oder?
Ja, das macht verdammte Mühe. Warum willst du dir die Mühe machen, wenn du das auch kopieren kannst? Wenn du deine Profs halbwegs einschätzen kannst und weißt, dass sie...
Was lesen die gerne? Gibt doch mal eine Anleitung.
Also wenn ich...
Wie bescheißt man am besten?
Das eine ist, ich würde natürlich gucken, dass ich schon im Studium mir die Themen für die Seminare und dann die hausarbeiten mir nehme, wo ich viel auswahl habe. Das ist natürlich sehr wichtig.
Wie also möglichst unobskure Themen?
Natürlich, damit du eben nicht so die Mühe hast, dir aus 30, 50 Arbeiten hinauszusuchen. Dann musst du dir eine Lehrkraft suchen, von der du weißt, dass sie das ohnehin nicht liest. Das ist ja in der Regel unter den Studenten ganz gut bekannt, wie du so betreut wirst. Ich bin der festen Überzeugung, wenn du dich nicht bescheuert anstellst, kannst du dich heute auch total durchmogeln. Du wirst am Ende natürlich zum Beispiel die Arbeiten gut lesen müssen, wenn du sie mündlich verteidigst. Du wirst sie lesen müssen.
Na gut, das kann man ja machen mit seiner eigenen abschlussarbeit lesen.
Das ist ja auch noch das Unfaire daran, dass du, und da sind wir schon wieder bei dem dritten Punkt, du lernst nie, dich mit dem Thema, also für denjenigen, der plagiert, mit dem Thema wirklich ausnahm zu setzen, dir eine Meinung zu bilden, dir verschiedene Werke anzusehen und zu reflektieren darüber. Und dann vielleicht sogar noch, wenn du jetzt Standing on the shoulders of giants noch was draufsetzen kannst.
Das ist eigentlich der Punkt, der mich bei dieser Gutenberg-Geschichte am meisten aufregt. Also wenn ich halt irgendwie so einen Typen habe, der sich seinen Doktor gekauft hat, das ist mittlerweile halt, also ich hab schon so viele Leute getroffen, die einen Doktortitel haben und einfach bescheuerte Idioten sind, dass ich also für mich persönlich dieser Titel selber nicht besonders viel Achtung in sich trägt. ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel natürlich. Danke.
Wir hatten das noch nicht erwähnt oder ich bin gerade in der Endphase und will demnächst meine eigene Dissertation abgeben, allerdings so richtig motiviert bin ich jetzt auch nicht gerade.
Die wird großartig werden.
Na ja, für dich ist sie ja nix wert.
Wenn du noch jemand zum Gegenwesen brauchst.
Nein, nein, der Titel ist nix wert, die Dissertation ist schon was wert.
So, aber genau, das ist der Punkt. Du hast ja den Anspruch eigentlich, gerade bei einem Doktortitel, dass du versuchst, die Wissenschaft voranzubringen. Also das ist ja eigentlich der Anspruch an einen Doktortitel, ist ja nicht, wie zum Beispiel irgendwie, was weiß ich, bei einer Bachelor-Arbeit oder so, einfach nur den Stand im Feld zu reflektieren und so darzulegen, dass du nicht verstanden hast, worum es geht, sondern die Wissenschaft voranzubringen. Das heißt also Neuerkenntnisse zu erarbeiten, irgendwie neue Ideen zu entwickeln, einfach die, ja, also den, den Stand.
Aber nicht nur für die Wissenschaft, für uns alle.
Für uns alle damit natürlich, na klar. Logischerweise. Also, und das ist natürlich der, ja, das ist schon so.
Na warte, der Heere-Anspruch, na klar, deswegen machen wir alle Doktor-Arbeiten.
Das ist der Grund, warum man Wissenschaft hat.
Ich weiß genau, was du meinst, aber das stimmt einfach irgendwie. Das hat mit der Realität nicht so viel zu tun.
Aber das ist, weswegen wir uns als Gesellschaft, Wissenschaft mit einem großen Aufwand leisten ist, weil wir die Hoffnung haben, dass es uns voranbringt. Das ist eigentlich der Grund. Das ist der Grund, warum wir Universitäten finanzieren, ist, weil wir gut ausgebildete Leute haben wollen und neue Ideen, das sind die beiden Gründe.
Eigentlich ist es doch wie hacken.
So, eigentlich ist es wie hacken, genau. Wir wollen halt einfach neue Sachen haben. Ich meine, wenn du dich hinsetzt und irgendwie älter neu implementierst, dann machst du das aus einem guten Grund.
Na ja, das rede ich mir auch immer ein. Na ja.
Gut, aber du versuchst es trotzdem einfach besser zu machen. Du versuchst es einfach zu verbessern. Wenn du dir das einfach nur plagierst und zusammenkopierst, dann bringst du einfach die Wissenschaft nicht voran. Im Gegenteil, da steckt halt dann wahrscheinlich keine neue Idee drin. Ich meine, das war ja auch...
Das war nicht deine eigene neue Idee.
Das fand ich ja die absolute Dreistigkeit bei dem Gutenberg, dass der, also aus was für minderwertigen Quellen der da teilweise zusammenkopiert hat und dann noch gesagt hat, dass er glaubt, dass trotzdem diese Arbeit einen hohen wissenschaftlichen Wert hat. Das hat er tatsächlich noch gesagt, ja.
Er hat sich auch hingestellt und gemeint, da sei kein Vorsatz und es sei irgendwie keine täuschung. Wie realistisch ist der? Also jetzt mal bei Gutenberg natürlich sowieso nicht, aber wenn jetzt jemand kommt, das finde ich eine interessante Frage generell. Gibt es überhaupt einen Fall, wo du sagen würdest, das ist mit Versehen erklärbar, wenn jemand kommt und bei dir ein Plagiat abgibt? Sagen wir mal, wenn da irgendwie zwei Zeilen kopiert sind. Also gibt es Fälle, wo du sagst, okay, das glaube ich dem, der hat einfach vergessen, hier eine Foto zu setzen?
In den Jahren war ein einzigen Fall, wo ich das geglaubt hab, da hat mir jemand einen glasklaren Plagiat abgegeben, aus drei, vier Stellen kopiert. Der hat mir glaubhaft machen können, dass das nicht seine Arbeit ist, die er mir abgeben sollte, sondern sein Vorbereitungs-Sheet. Also der hat mir tatsächlich ein bisschen...
Ich hab die falsche Mail geschickt, oder was?
Also das hab ich ihm dann auch geglaubt, weil er mir am Tag darauf die eigentliche Arbeit abgab.
Und die war besser?
Na klar, die war überhaupt eine Arbeit, die hatte eine Widerung und so. Und er hatte mir eher so ein... Nix, Schnipsel.
Nee, aber ich meinte jetzt, dir gibt jemand eine Arbeit ab.
Hat er ja.
Nee, aber ich mein also eine Arbeit. Und du findest einen Klagiaterin. Und der kommt mit der ausrede, das war ein Versehen. Da wollte ich eigentlich... Gibt es irgendeinen Fall, wo das glaubwürdig ist? Also selbst wenn es nur irgendwie ein, zwei Stellen sind?
Nee, aus meiner Sicht eigentlich nicht. Also wenn jemand Text von anderen in seiner Arbeit kopiert, dann kann man sich glaube ich nachher nicht hindrehen, dass man ja noch mal was ran schreiben wollte. Und ich finde auch, wenn jemand jetzt so ein bisschen wieder guten Begräten macht, so ach, ich bin Überblick verloren. Ich bin da schon selber nicht mehr durchgestiegen. Am Ende hat er die Texteile kopiert. Was wollte er denn damit tun?
Also das fand ich auch spannend, dass seine ausrede im Grunde war, er müsste selber noch mal gucken und er kann sich nicht daran... Also er findet nicht, dass da betrogen wurde.
Also ich meine, das war doch wirklich der Lacher im Bundestag, oder?
Das war der Oberlacher. Ja, aber ich hab die Formulierung lustig gefunden, weil die für mich ja nicht so klang, als er dementiert habe, er habe nicht betrogen, sondern es sei überhaupt nicht betrogen worden. Das heißt, für mich klang das so, genau, er hat einen Ghostwriter und er versucht jetzt gerade, sich selbst gegenüber zu rechtfertigen, warum er ihm Geld gegeben hat. So klang das für mich. So nach dem Motto, ne, ne, der wird mich schon nicht beschissen haben, der hat schon gute Arbeit gelassen. So klang das für mich.
Also wenn ich jetzt über Plakierte nachdenke und diese Arbeit, die ich in großen Teilen mit dabei lesen hab, die übrigens auch nicht ist.
Die bestgelesene Arbeit in der Geschichte.
Die ist auch nicht so uninteressant.
Also der Bundesrepublik. Na, warum geht's denn? Erklär doch mal.
Die Genese sozusagen der Verfassung und der hat ja so ein bisschen so Rechtsvergleichung und so. Also ist nicht so uninteressant, kann man, ich hab nicht die ganze Arbeit gelesen, aber ziemlich große Stücken. Und interessant ist, dass mir stilistische Brücher eigentlich nicht so aufgefallen sind. Der hat so eine gewisse Art, wie er schreibt und so bestimmte Worte, die auch immer wieder auftauchen, die auch immer wieder... Freilich.
Das war eins der Worte, die er da geändert hat. Das fand ich super, weil es so schön bayerisch ist.
Oder zu weihen. Also die hat er ja auch eigentlich immer wieder da so in die Texte hineingemacht. Sie haben ja jetzt in dem guten Plak teilweise diese Übersicht, was genau für Worte er wo eingefügt wird. Da hat er schon so ein bisschen seinen Stil übergestülpt. Die Frage ist nur, ob es sein Stil ist. Also oder wessen. Und nun gibt es ja diverse Gerüchte.
Man hört ja so... Das kann man vielleicht mal erwähnen. Wir haben uns ja mal umgehört in gewöhnlich gut unterrichteten Kreisen.
Genau.
Und uns ist also zu Ohren gekommen, dass es da nicht nur offensichtlich einen Ghostwriter gibt, sondern dass sogar bekannt ist, welcher Ghostwriter das sein soll.
Also das ist schon ein gewissen Klatsch.
Also unter den Berliner Journalisten wird das auch relativ ausführlich gerichtet. Und wohl auch im Bundestag gibt es einige Leute, die meinen schon relativ genau zu wissen, wer denn der Ghostwriter war.
Wir können ja mal wetten, wenn der Ghostwriter auf dem Tisch liegt. Kann er sich da noch halten?
Nein.
Das haben wir aber schon mal gesagt. Wir haben schon mal gesagt, dass er sich nicht halten können wird, als das gute Plug-Wiki immer größer wurde.
Also der Punkt ist mit dem Ghostwriter...
Ich hab das nicht gesagt. Ich hab gesagt, im Gegenteil.
Ah ja, fehl voll.
Aber ich finde, dass er jetzt natürlich jetzt schon zurücktreten muss. Hör mal.
Natürlich finde ich.
Das ist bei den Akten, was ich gesagt habe, da steht drin, kannst ja mal meinen Beobachtungsbeamten fragen.
Aber ich glaube, der Punkt ist, dass er wurde im Bundestag explizit gefragt, ob er seiner Arbeit ist. Und zwar richtig explizit so, dass es keinerlei ausweg gab. Also der wurde so gefragt.
ausgerechnet. Das wäre ja irgendwie nochmal, oh, so ein Dirfad, die müssen ihn bestimmt nicht vorgehalten kriegen.
Also halt so. Und wenn jetzt rauskommt, dass es einen Großstrater gab, dann hat er den Bundestag offen angelogen.
Na hat er jetzt schon.
Ja, aber in einer Art und Weise, wo er sich nicht mehr rauswieseln kann.
Na bisher ist das halt eine Notlüge, wo irgendwie manche Leute noch Verständnis für haben, weil, weißt du, die haben eine Koalition mit der FDP. Das kennen die nicht anders.
Also hat jetzt den Bundestag offen belogen, zu sagen, dass das keine bewusste täuschung ist. Was ist denn das andere als eine Lüge?
Ja, bloß in dem Augenblick, wo sozusagen es ein einfacher Fakt ist, ein Fakt ist, der sich nicht auf 380 Seiten verteilt und der irgendwie hier mal und da mal und hier ein bisschen mitpicking und da eine Fußnutze und da ein Zitat vergessen und hier reingeschnitten und da stilistisch angepasst und da ein bisschen übersetzt ist. Sondern einfach die Frage, hat das selber geschrieben, hat das nicht selber geschrieben? So und er hat...
Aber wieso? Es ist doch eigentlich noch dreister, wenn er das selber war, wenn er auch noch derjenige ist, der diese zusammenkommt.
aus meiner Sicht ist das korrekt, aber rein formal ist es so, wenn er nicht selber geschrieben hat. Also dann ist es tatsächlich ja auch noch eine...
Es gibt halt keine guten Dienstleister mehr.
Ich kann es ja nicht sagen.
Es gibt halt keine guten Dienstleister mehr. Immer schwieriger, gutes Personal zu finden.
Es gibt einen großen Markt für diese Dienstleister.
Ziemlich gute Ghostwriter mittlerweile.
Wenn du hier noch in der Mott-Uni in der Mitte gehst, hast du doch durchaus an den gelben Brettern die...
Die aushänge, ja?
Ja, die hast du in Hilfe bei der Doktorarbeit und so.
Es gab auch in letzter Zeit interessante Interviews und Artikel zu lesen, wo sich Journalisten mit so einem Ghostwriter unterhalten haben und über deren Motive gesprochen haben.
Was kostet denn sowas? Hast du da einen Einblick?
Also ich denke, du siehst halt, du kannst die Wärmung sehen. Da steht ja durchaus öfter mal ein Preis. Ich denke, für eine gute Dessertation zahlst du ja vor allen Dingen deshalb, weil die Service anbietet, die auch noch den Doktorvater suchen, den passenden. Also da zahlst du schon eher eine fünfstellige Summe, aber keine hohe fünfstellige Summe.
Also so eine Zahl, die ich mal gehört habe von einem Ghostwriter ist das halt für eine gute Doktorarbeit, je nachdem, wie die Vorbereitung von dem zukünftigen Doktor schon kommt, so zwischen 15.000 und 30.000 Euro kassiert. So, das sitzt dann auch ein halbes Jahr da dran, also das ist halt schon so.
Aber die 30.000 ist dann eher schon mit Vermittlung, dass der Doktorvater das macht.
Nee, das macht ja nicht die Dienstleistung, das nimmt er für dumme. Also nimmt er für dumme, wo er halt die Verteidigung intensiv vorbereiten muss und den dann noch coachen muss.
Ich fand es so lustig, dass übrigens fast unter jedem Gutenberg-Artikel diese Werbung war, ne?
Automatisch.
Ja, die automatisch generierte Werbung für diese. Es fand ich so schreienkomisch. Am Anfang habe ich immer noch Screenshots gemacht, aber das habe ich dann schnell erlassen, weil die überall war.
Ich finde es super, ja. Ich freue mich ja auch, dass jetzt in den Artikeln anfängt, wenn es generell um Plagiate geht, dass da einfach Gutenberg-Bilder auftauchen. Auch wenn es überhaupt nicht um ihn ging, sondern er ist jetzt einfach verbunden mit Plagiat. Das gefällt mir sehr gut.
Ja, ich denke, das wird auch nie mehr loswerden. Das gehört sich auch so. Sie hatten jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das lesen habt, bei Spohn hatten Sie diesen Prinz von Preußen, diesen Interview. Der Prinz von Preußen, ich glaube, der ist wirklich Wilhelm. Der ist wirklich der Prinz von Preußen.
Überraschung, der ist noch alle Friedrich-
oder Wilhelm- Der ist vor einigen Jahren damit erwischt worden, was sehr peinlich war. Und es gab auch einen Medien-Skandal schon ein bisschen her. Und den hatten Sie jetzt mal so 40 Jahre danach befragt, wie er heute dazu steht. Und? Das war ihm damals, er hat geschildert, wie peinlich ihm das war. Und er hat sich tatsächlich danach hingesetzt und nochmal einen wirklichen Doktor. Genau. Und er hat natürlich auch nochmal ein bisschen erzählt, wie er in der Familie ist. Irgendwann musst du doch irgendwie deinem Vater gestehen. Du bist eben der große Schummler. Und vor allen Dingen hat er aber auch geschildert, was damals sein Grund war. Und das war ebenso wie bei meinen Studenten häufig, ist auch eine gewisse Überforderung. Nun halte ich den Gutenberg nicht für unintelligent.
Ich sollte nicht denken, dass er so doof ist, ne?
Nee, aber das ist natürlich auch... Ich muss schon mal sagen, das ist reichst und dumm, was er gemacht hat.
Warte mal, warte mal. Also ich halte das schon für, also ich will nicht sagen nachvollziehbar, aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, wie wenn du irgendwie aus so einer Freiherr-von-und-zu-Familie kommst...
Oh ja, Küchenpsychologie, komm, wir machen mal Küchen.
Ich kann mir das schon vorstellen, dass da ein gewisser Druck auf dir nass ist. Und dass du dann, egal wie trivial dein Thema ist, irgendwie den Andokasten musst du da jetzt eine bombastische Arbeit abliefern.
Du wohnst aus dem Schloss. Du bist so reich. Wohnt der im Schloss?
Also wir haben ja gefordert zurück zum Schloss.
Ja, das war ja nicht umsonst die Forderung, die hat ja ihr Schloss.
Na klar. Du wohnst auf dem Schloss. Du bist so reich, dass du nie arbeiten müsstest, ja. Deine Frau ist auch noch eine Bismarck. Dein Vater ist ein Dirigent der Weltberühmtes. Und ohne Frage ein faszinierender Künstler.
Dein Großvater war der Architekt der Koalition.
Auch noch Nazi-Widerständler. Du kommst irgendwie, du hast einen Stammbomb, der geht zurück irgendwie in die Zeit mit 1500, keine Ahnung, und 37 Vornamen.
Das kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass der irgendwie Druck hat.
Der Druck wird schon ordentlich gewesen sein, ne?
Das hat er sogar selber gesagt, ne?
Das hat er ja oft selber zugegeben. Um so drei Jahre anzunehmen, er käme mit so einem Scheiß durch. Aber noch, was mich noch mehr ärgert, ist...
Du, aber das kennen wir doch aus allen öffentlichen Projekten, dass wenn du da eine Weile drin bist, kriegst du so einen Tunnelblick und kriegst nicht mehr mit, was du da für eine Scheiße machst.
Das ist ja kein öffentlicher Punkt.
Nein, aber das ist bei allen Projekten so. Also wir sehen es besonders gut bei öffentlichen Projekten. Es gibt ja auch immer wieder irgendwie Softwareprojekte, wo du dich fragst, wie ein Computerspiel oder so was, was rauskommt, und wo du siehst, wie können die so was releasen? Wenn du an so was arbeitest, kriegst du einen Tunnelblick. Und wenn du alleine an so was arbeitest, dann fehlt auch noch das Korrektiv, was schon eh schwierig ist.
Dafür hast du deine Doktorbetreuer.
Eigentlich, aber offensichtlich ja nicht. Beziehungsweise in diesem Fall kommen ja noch die großzügigen Spenden dazu. Da möchte ich auch nicht in der Haut von den Doktorvater stecken, der jetzt irgendwie selbst, nehmen wir mal an, du bist jetzt der Doktorvater und du erkennst, da kommt jemand mit einem dreisten Plagiat und der ist irgendwie der Hauptsponsor deiner Fakultät. Das ist sicher auch keine schöne Position.
Na ja, ich überlege mir das. Da war der Heberle ja schon ein älterer Herr. Ich denke nicht, dass der vor drei, vier Jahren schon Google benutzt hat. Das hätte er ja nicht mehr tun müssen. Das ist ja was die meisten jetzt auch in dem guten Plagg-Wiki tun. Ich denke, der wird...
Und der wird einfach den Verdacht nicht gehabt haben. Der wird einfach den Verdacht nicht gehabt haben.
Weil?
Na, weil von und zu Guttenberg.
Von und zu Guttenberg.
Wir haben ja nicht mal das Vorwort gesprochen.
Das Vorwort?
Das Vorwort, dieser dreiste Vorwort. Also man muss sich mal überlegen, das haben ja meine plagierenden Studenten bisher nicht gemacht. Das ist das einzige, wo sie sich die Mühe geben, wenigstens mal ein paar Absätze zu schreiben, jetzt für eine kleine hausarbeit oder Seminararbeit. Was haben sie da eigentlich gemacht? Also zu sagen, nur mal gelesen haben, was haben sie zusammen kopiert und wenigstens das noch selber formulieren. Das ist immer sehr schön, weil man hat dann...
Und nicht nur das hat es, aber man hat das auch kopiert.
Man hat dann eine Textstelle, wo man vergleichen kann, wie sie wirklich schreiben können, mit dem man dahinter kommt. Das ist immer sehr praktisch. Aber nicht mehr das. Ich meine nichts gegen Frau Zehnfenich, die einen schönen FAZ-Artikel geschrieben hat. Aber im Vorwort... Also da fällt mir ein Schmerz ein. Also da musst du doch auch genau keinen eigenen Gedanken haben, den du dort darlegen willst. Da ist auch nichts außer gehende Lehre im Gehirn.
Ich glaube, da ging es auch gar nicht drum. Ich meine, der hat echt andere Sorgen gehabt. Der wollte Politiker werden und hat sich gedacht, nicht die, die nimmt halt mit. Der ist ja auch nicht mehr viel wert. Das haben wir ja schon am Anfang dargelegt. Das ist ja auch im Grunde nur noch unter CDU-Altwählern und Mitgliedern.
Aber das sollte man nicht unterschätzen.
Nee, aber ich meine, so für die normale Bevölkerung mag das ja tatsächlich stimmen, was in dieser Talkshow war. Nach dem Motto, der ist halt ein zuguten Berg, da braucht der noch einen Titel. Wozu braucht der noch einen Doktor?
Das ist ja, was die Leute sich fragen, aber das ist natürlich überhaupt nicht die Frage dabei.
Na schon, klar.
Na, was hängt da mal zusammen, ob er das hätte brauchen können? Es hängt doch eigentlich nur damit zusammen, inwieweit hat er betrogen.
Na wieso hat er denn überhaupt einen Doktor gemacht, wenn er so wenig involviert war, dass er da eine Arbeit nicht schreiben kann? Tja. Das ist doch die Frage, wenn er den gar nicht gebraucht hätte.
Ich denke mal, die Sachen mit dem familiären Druck spürt er schon.
Das wird einfach der familiäre Druck gewesen sein.
Naja, sich damit zu schmücken ist natürlich auch für das eigene Ego nicht schlecht.
Hast du so einen Überblick, wie es in verschiedenen Fachbereichen so ist? Irgendwie, sagen wir mal, Geisteswissenschaft oder ist es irgendwie Informatik oder so?
Also du siehst natürlich, dass es Zweifelchen gibt, wo ein bisschen der usus anders ist. Das ist bei Medizin und bei Jura. Man sieht das bei der Medizin ganz viele Doktoren machen, weil man erwartet, dass ein Arzt ein Doktor ist. Das ist ganz merkwürdig. Das ist in anderen Wissenschaften nicht so stark. Und du siehst, dass in der Jurisprudenz die Quote auch ein bisschen höher ist. Das liegt aber auch daran, dass nicht alle Volljuristen sind. Gutenberg ist kein Volljurist. Der hatte zweite Staatsexamen nie gemacht. Er hat also das erste gemacht und danach den Doktor geschrieben und ist also zu sagen, er könnte kein Anwalt sein und hat keine Befähigung zum Richteramt.
Du testest nur Halbjurist?
Ja, man nennt es Halbjurist, also kein Volljurist.
Die Schrater kannst du halt aussetzen, indem du eine Doktorarbeit machst.
Genau, wenn du sowieso nie Anwalt oder Richter werden würdest. Aber wir haben auch noch überhaupt nicht so markum laude.
Oh ja, red mal über so markum laude.
Was heißt denn überhaupt für die von unseren Hörern, die es nicht wissen?
Das ist das einzige wirklich hohe Prädikat, was sozusagen weit oberhalb der besten Arbeiten ist, die abgegeben werden.
Die sind kein pfuscher.
So richtig plack, so richtig, jetzt hätte ich quasi gesagt, naja, also so richtig Prädikat und so ganz oberhalb des Schnitz der Besten. Das hat er bekommen. Das ist ja auch bizar.
Ja, aber was anderes geht auch nicht, oder, an so einer Stelle, wenn der irgendwie deine Fakultät im Grunde bezahlt.
Wieso denn? Der Hebele, sein Doktorvater, der ist ein allseits bekannter, gerühmter Wissenschaftler. Naja, der gilt als Autorität und Koryphäe in seinem Fach. Warum?
Naja, aber der wird auch dankbar sein, dass er da im Grunde seinen Platz hat, in dem er vor sich hin machen kann.
Wieso muss er diesen jungen, artligen, gegäten, irgendwie so Makum lauter geben, nur weil die Röhnkliniken mal eine halbe Million drüber schieben?
Ja.
Das muss man doch nicht, oder?
Na wieso? Ich meine, wenn du da ein paar Jahre in Ruhe forschen kannst.
Naja, naja, gut.
Und irgendwie nichts weiter machen musst, ja.
Frank klickt hier derweil die Bilder von unserer Demo, die wirklich gelungen ist.
Na ja, ich sehe gerade die.
hunderttausende demonstrieren in Berlin gegen Gutenberg. Ist ja toll.
Tagespiegeltitel.
hunderttausende? Naja, na gut.
Die 1000 hat Constanze gerade rein plagiert.
Ich entschuldige mich. Denn ich entschuldige mich jetzt einfach einmal, denn ist alles wieder gut.
Es waren versehen.
Es waren versehen. Also die hunderttausende waren.
Ich war auch nicht bewusst. Ich hab's auch versehen.
Nee, haben wir falsch abgeschrieben.
Ich verstehe jedenfalls auch nicht, warum dieser bekannte Poff in der ganzen Zeit jetzt kein Wort dazu verloren hat. Der hat sich ganz außen verabschiedet und sagt nichts.
Das ist ihm halt peinlich. Das kann ich schon verstehen.
Der kann sich doch jetzt mal äußern.
Er könnte sich jetzt distanzieren, aber das geht halt nicht, wenn der Gutenberg irgendwie die Kohle rüberwachsen lässt. Da kann sich nicht distanzieren.
Da sind wir bei einem eigentlichen strukturellen Problem, nämlich die Unterfinanzierung der Bildung und die Frage, inwieweit Drittmittel heute eigentlich unsere Hochschulen finanzieren. Da sind wir bei einem riesigen Problem.
Das ist doch aber toll. Das ist doch die neue Bildungsreform, dass die Unis jetzt ihren Wert zeigen durch Patente und durch eingeworbener Drittmittel. Und das ist doch toll, wenn jetzt irgendwie...
Ja, und dann bilden wir nämlich auch nicht mehr aus...
Ach, ausbildung, völlig überbewertet.
Nein, wir bilden überhaupt nicht mehr aus für die Wissensmehrung, sondern wir bilden für den Markt aus. Dann können wir endlich die Fachkräfte, die die Wirtschaft braucht, aus den Universitäten rausholen können. Und nicht mehr für den Erkennungsbereich.
Dabei ist es doch viel billiger, wenn man die aus Indien importiert, oder?
Ich glaube, dass einer der wesentlichen Problempunkte ist, dass...
Widersprich doch mal laut und entnervt.
Wieso?
Das verlangt Constanze gerade von dir.
Nein, nein, ich hab ihn nur angestoßen, damit er nicht weiter die Bilder klickt, sondern um sich mit unserem Gespräch zu binden.
Die Bilder sind schon recht schön.
Ja, die sind schon sehr schön, das stimmt. Ich denke, dass der Grund ist, dass die ausbildung, wie wir zum Beispiel in Holland ja schon sehen, immer mehr ausgerichtet wird, eben nicht auf tatsächlichen akademischen Nachwuchs, sondern auf Trainierbarkeit, also auf die Fähigkeit, dass du halt irgendwie da dich erst nochmal zehn Jahre als Praktikant ausbilden lässt. Und dann hast du halt dann halt irgendwie die Fähigkeit erworben auf einen Job, der irgendwie nur so halb deine geistige Fähigkeit beansprucht.
Und das hat auch damals so, dass die Quote der Studenten, überhaupt natürlich die Quote der Abiturienten und dann später auch die Quote der Studenten natürlich noch zugenommen hat. Das wir immer mehr Leute, die ein Hochschulstudium anstreben. Es gibt noch. Natürlich nicht immer damit zu tun, dass die gerne akademische weinen wollen und ein großes Erkenntnisinteresse haben, sondern natürlich gehört das in die Vita heute.
Nein, das hat auch einfach damit zu tun, dass es immer weniger Jobs gibt, wo du ohne ein Hochschulstudium noch irgendwie was werden kannst. Das ist schon so. Das ist halt so das, was früher mal der Facharbeiter war, wo du halt einfach ein gutes auskommen hattest, einfach durch handwerkliche Talente. Das wird ja immer weniger, das gibt es ja kaum noch. Ich meine, die allermeisten Leute machen ja heutzutage was mit Medien.
Guten Tag auch! Ja, das haben wir eigentlich immer noch nicht besprochen, diese unsägliche Bild-Kampagne.
Die Bild-Kooperation?
Ich habe ja seit einiger Zeit auf dem von mir ja sehr geschätzten Bildblock auch so nachvollzogen, die auch so ein bisschen durchgezählt haben, wie in den letzten Monaten wie viele Meldungen zu ihm und seiner Frau in der Bild waren und mit welchem Tenor. Das ist ja schon spannend zu sehen.
Ich glaube, das ist so eine Art Stockholm-Syndrom, was das Bildblock da betreibt. Ich kann das gar nicht lesen. Ich glaube, die haben sich da so irgendwie...
Na gut, aber es ist jemand mal dokumentiert, ne?
Wir sollten diesen Deal zumindest noch mal erklären, was da gerade das stinkende Detail ist, was heute auch auf der Demo zu lauten Rufen geführt hat. Es gab nämlich die Springer-Presse als einziges medienhaus in Deutschland, die sich hinter Guttenberg gestellt haben in der Plagiats-Affäre.
Umfragen technisch jetzt, ja.
Umfragen und auch von ihrem meinungsjournalismus her und von ihren Meldungen her. Die haben jetzt ausgerechnet das Füllhorn der Bundeswehr abbekommen, die nämlich eine große Werbekampagne schalten will zur Anwerbung von neuen......Fraveling. Ja, für Kanonenfutter, für die jetzt umstrukturierte Bundeswehr.
Wir haben aber tatsächlich auch ein Nachwuchproblem.
Natürlich haben wir Nachwuchsprobleme. Und da gehen sie halt zur Bildzeitung. Also auch gar nicht zur kompletten Springer-Presse, sondern vor allem zur Bildzeitung. Und das riecht schon so, als wenn das quasi der Dank von Guttenberg ist, dafür, dass sie ihm die Stange halten.
Ja, aber die Bild kann ihn nicht verlieren. Das Win-Win. Also die Kampanten nühen. Selbst wenn er jetzt zurücktritt.
Wir können doch noch seine Frau featurieren von wegen.
Natürlich.
Also der Kampf gegen die Kinderpornos.
Die Auflage wird schon...
Also ich glaube, wenn er tatsächlich gezwungen wird, zurückzutreten, dann werden die eine, dann werden die tatsächlich eine sehr anti-illitäre Kampagne fahren. Also dann werden die halt diesen, diese intellektuellen, haben unseren einzigen Politikstar wegen irgendwelchen Kleinigkeiten vernichtet, Kampagne fahren.
Wegen ein paar Fußnoten, Zitierfehlerchen. Diese Verhandlungen nerven mich auch. Schummeleien heißt das immer.
Das ist halt so ein, das ist halt denke ich mal so ein, und was wir da halt haben, ist eben ja genau die Abkopplung von Geist in Politik.
Das ist ja nun eigentlich ein altes Ding, oder? Das kennen wir schon aus dem Osten. Die Idee, dass die Intelligenz ja böse ist und eigentlich gegen das Volk arbeitet und die, dass man da egalisierend eingreifen muss.
Das ist aber lange nicht mehr so manifest gewesen. Also nicht mehr, war lange nicht mehr so ein durchziehendes Thema.
Na ja, es hat natürlich einen gewissen Schmack, dass dieser Volkstribun, den das einfache Volk so gerne mag, eigentlich so totale Elite ist, durch und durch.
Das lustige, also Elite ist ein Stichwort, auf das ich auch nochmal ansprechen wollte. Wir haben es ja schon mal in einer Alternativlos-Sendung angesprochen, dass im Bildungsbereich Elitenbildung so funktioniert, dass nicht die Guten befördert werden, sondern das Mittelmaß und die Schlechten. Denn die Guten gehen weg und der Nachfolger erinnert sich nicht mehr an den Quid pro Quo, den du gemacht hast. Und unter dem Aspekt finde ich nämlich auch diese Summa cum laude plötzlich erklärbar. Wenn du einfach sagst, der beste Mitarbeiter ist jemand, gegen den du was in der Hand hast. Und wenn du weißt, der hat seine Arbeit plagiiert, ist doch das Beste, was du gegen ihn in der Hand haben kannst. Und dementsprechend kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass die sagen...
Sie sind jetzt gezogen, also warum wurde diese Akte jetzt rausgeholt?
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Akte rausgeholt wurden, sondern das hat einfach im Internet gefunden. Ja, das ist natürlich scheiße gelaufen. Ja, also ich glaube nicht, dass den gerade irgendjemand zurücktreten sehen will innerhalb der Region.
Die Story ist doch anders. Na, das ist doch dieser Bremer Professor, der eine Rezension geschrieben hat, der hat auch der Beginn. Dann hat es die Süddeutsche aufgenommen. Im Übrigen ist, wenn man diese, die kann man ja nachlesen, das bei den kritischen Juristen in der Zeitschrift. Da geht es ja nicht nur um die wenigen Plagiate, die er am anderen gefunden hat, sondern er hat natürlich auch versucht, die Arbeit juristisch einzuschätzen. Er ist ein Juraprofessor. Und er misst ihr natürlich auch, vom Erkenntnis her wäre jetzt sehr wenig bei. Und er schreibt, was ich selber übrigens auch fand, dass es lange Passagen gibt, wo er den Konvent, den Verfassungskonvent, so beschreibend wiedergibt. Das ist langweilsig zu tun, das ist wirklich sehr langweilig. Also ich hab ja nur große Stücke gelesen davon. Also er greift die auch inhaltlich ein. Also der Punkt ist, dass dieser renommierte Prof einen Sommer vergeben hat für eine offensichtliche, auch inhaltliche unterdurchschnittliche Arbeit. Also du überleg dir mal, du bist doch ein Prof, du sitzt in deinem Professoren-Sessel, du bist unabhängig, niemand kann dir irgendwas. Aber das ging doch jahrelang gut. So eine Arbeit, naja, selbst wenn er jetzt das Plagiat nicht gibt, ist einfach langweilig und all.
Guck mal, du gibst einen Sommer?
Na ja, wenn er dir halt eine dreiviertel Million für dein Lehrstück gibt, gibst du ihm halt einen Sommer.
So konkret war er halt nicht.
Naja, aber ungefähr so war es.
Naja, das war eine dreiviertel Million, die da geschlossen ist.
Da schloss es ja übrigens auch ziemlich in der Nähe, ne? Also auch örtlich.
Du, zu Bamberg? Bei Rothen.
Der Professor hat sich einen Freund fürs Leben geholt und es war ja nicht klar, dass Guttenberg zur Bundeswehr geht. Der hätte ja auch Bildungsminister werden können.
Wirtschaftsminister?
Wirtschaftsminister, naja klar.
War er doch.
Also ich meine.
Eigentlich ist er ja Außenpolitiker. Spezialist für Außenpolitik.
Aber das war doch nur, weil er ein alter Herr Außenpolitiker war oder nicht?
Ich hab jetzt schon mal erzählt, wie er das allererste Mal auf Guttenberg gestoßen ist. Es war im ehemaligen Stromgeschütz, im ehemaligen Nachrichtenmagazin. Das war irgendwann schon lange Zeit her. Also Print. So ein einseitiger Artikel, wo er wählen konnte. Da hatten sie schon total...
Also einseitig im Sinne von auf einer Seite.
Ja, auf einer Seite.
Nicht inhaltlich einseitig.
Genau. Da stand er noch als Außenpolitiker und Shootingstar der CSU. Da hatten die so ein geniales Bild, wo er wieder mit so einer hellblauen Klawatte wieder mal immer too much von der Kleidung her. Und schon sofort... Also die gegelten Haare, war alles schon damals so. Und in so einer artligen Pose. Das ist mir so in Erinnerung geblieben, weil sie hatten ihn so ein bisschen aufgebaut als der neue Konkurrent von Söder. Weil Söder war ja eigentlich mal der Kronprinz. Das ist ja irgendwie auch echt abgestürzt.
Ja und jetzt der sein, dieser, also ich meine, die haben ja auch sonst niemand. Es gibt da noch diesen Kauder. Also die CSU kann aber auch echt ein bisschen leid tun.
Das ist jetzt interessant, was passiert denn jetzt? Also nehmen wir mal irgendwie keine Ahnung. Morgen kommt der Spiegel raus mit irgendwie.
Wir haben den Großweiter gefunden, der packt raus.
Wir haben den Großweiter und Mittwoch sagt irgendwie Gutenberg, irgendwie macht einen Scheiß alleine. Was passiert denn dann?
Naja, erst mal muss Merkel ihr Kabinett umbilden.
Na Merkel wird das erst mal nicht annehmen. Das ist erst mal ein paar Tage vergehen damit, dass Merkel das nicht annimmt.
Nee, das passiert sofort. Kann sie nicht.
Also das kann sie nicht tun.
Das haben sie bisher noch immer gemacht.
Nee, das funktioniert nur deswegen so, dass in Deutschland ist halt Tradition, dass Minister nicht zurückgetreten werden, sondern immer zurücktreten.
So wie der Jung vor ihm. Du gehst dann hin und sagst Guten Tag jetzt.
Ich möchte nicht mehr. Genau. Und sie kann ihn höchstens daran hindern, zurückzutreten.
Ja, eben.
Hallo, die selber Doktor, bitte.
Nee, das wird sie in dieser Situation vermutlich, also wenn er zurücktritt wegen Ghostwriter, vermutlich nicht.
Wir haben super Wahljahr. Die haben nix. Die haben nix. aus der Gutenberg. Die kann ihn nicht zurücktreten lassen.
Lass uns mal kurz durchschmieren.
Die haben jetzt schon, ich meine, hast du dieses Wahlergebnis in Hamburg gesehen? Die CDU steht mit dem Rücken zur Wand.
Ja, Hamburg ist schon speziell.
Die haben nix in der Hand, ja, aber ich meine.
Der Punkt ist aber vermutlich, also die Frage ist halt, was passiert, wenn sie ihn halten? Weil, also was ich aus den Konservativen, also aus den wirklichen Konservativen. CDU, Stammwähler, milieushöre, also und zwar so den Leuten, den alten grauen Herren, die eigentlich dieses Land regieren. So, die haben so richtig die Schnauze voll. Die betrachten als Verrat, was die CDU da gerade tut, und zwar Verrat an den paar konservativen Idealen, die sie noch hatten.
Anstand, Ehrlichkeit, Vertrauen.
Genau, was man alles mit der CDU...
Ja gut, aber was die da halt... Was die halt immer noch ernieren. Also war ja auch so schön, diese... Du hattest sie gerade geblockt, ne, dass ja diese Veranstaltungen mit Werten in Führung gehen. Und wer war der Ersatz, den sie hingeschickt haben?
Kauder.
Kauder. ausgerechnet Kauder, ja.
Habt ihr diese bizarre Interview mit dem Kauder über die christlichen Werte und zu sagen, das Religiöse in der Politik gelesen?
Nee.
Um Gottes Willen, wo war das denn? Im Bayern-Kurier?
Nee, nee, da war auch ein Bremsspiegel.
Also ich kann ja den Bayern-Kurier empfehlen, muss ich sagen. Ich hab den ja kürzlich erst entdeckt, das csu-hausblock. Das ist so unglaublich, was die da publizieren.
Ach die haben doch immer keine Links.
Wo du denkst, das muss von der Titanik betrieben werden oder so. Weil das kann unmöglich die Realität sein, das können die nicht publizieren, sowas. Oh mein Gott.
Wir nehmen an, Mittwoch tut er zurück.
Was für Mittwoch soll er sich noch halten?
Na von mir aus tut er auch... Also eine Demo müssen wir wahrscheinlich noch machen, bis er zurück tut. Na gut.
Nehmen wir mal ein... Schöne Schäder.
Die CSU ist jetzt schon in 50 Prozent.
Merkel muss ihr Kabinett umbilden. Was passiert denn?
Dafür musst du den Proporz beibehalten.
Das muss wieder einer aus der CDU sein.
Es muss nicht unbedingt der Verteidigungskurs vor sein, man könnte aber noch mal eine Rohade machen.
Also was ich ja den absoluten Brüller finde, ist, dass das Verteidigungsministerium eigentlich schon immer so ein Abstellgleis ist. Da tust du so Leute wie Scharping hin.
Weißt du?
Ja, so Leute, die du auf jeden Fall...
Ja, plus der Punkt war, dass sie... Das hat noch keiner politisch übernimmt. Sie mussten aber in dieses Verteidigungsministerium gerade jemand setzen, der da tatsächlich diese Reformen durchdrücken kann. Also den Abkehr von der Wehrpflicht. Ich meine, das muss man sagen. Das Einzige, was man diesem Mann bisher zu gut halten kann, ist, dass er in der Lage war, diese Wehrpflicht abzuschaffen. Ob das jetzt nun selber war, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich war es eher sein Staatssekretär. Und der hat es nur plagiert oder so. Aber zumindest unter seiner ministeriellen Ägide ist die Wehrpflicht abgeschafft worden. Das muss man ihm mal zu gut halten. Wir wollen ja nicht nur meckern, ne?
Wie weit das er aus unserer Armee jetzt einen Söldner hermacht, das kann man aber auch noch kritisch sehen.
Das kann man kritisch sehen, aber das ist, glaube ich, als Weibliche hat man das da einfacher.
Ja klar, ich muss bei dem Schrödel nicht mitmachen. Aber da muss auch kein Händlicher, du kannst verweigern, jeder kann verweigern.
Da musst du aber Zivildienst machen, das dauert länger. Du musst mal vielleicht mal eine Frau erläutern. Als Mann hast du immer die Wahl gehabt, entweder du gehst zur Armee oder du machst Zivildienst und dann bist du drei Monate länger da und wischst alten Leuten den Arsch ab, ist auch nicht unbedingt irgendwie.
Das ist doch ein Klischee, das machen doch ja nicht so viele.
Nein, aber der Punkt ist, du hast die Wahl zwischen zwei, die nicht wünschenswert sind.
Du kannst doch total verweigern.
Du kannst total verweigern, ja mach mal, viel Spaß.
Ey, die Terz hatte doch neulich diese 100 Briefe oder so.
Traditionell konnte man nach Berlin ziehen. Das war immer der ausweg und deswegen sind hier die ganzen Lutschen in Berlin gelandet. Und ausgerechnet zu dem Jahr, weißt du, wo es dann hier nach dem Maueröffnung das erste, was sie hier irgendwie zustande gekriegt haben, ist, dass sie hier ein Kreiswehrersatzamt eingeführt haben.
Also dieser Artikel, wo wir gerade überwefflicht sind, das war eines der herzerwärmsten Geschichten, die ich seit langem gelesen habe, war dieser hohen Triefen der Artikel, die Reportage im Spiegel aus dem Kreiswehrersatzamt. Wunderbar. Der Triefte so, der...
Hat mich fast versöhnt mit Ihnen.
Ja, das muss man immer... Also, wir kamen immer wieder auf die Positivliste, wenn wir das so vortragen.
Das würde ich eigentlich auch mal ganz gerne machen. Ich würde gerne mal einen Podcast haben, wo Leute, die irgendwie mit 20 oder 21, also männliche Leute irgendwie beim Bund waren, ihre Geschichten erzählen. Das hat man ja immer bei den Lagerfondsituationen. Da sitzen zwei, drei männliche zusammen und dann fangen sie ernst zu erzählen, wie sie bei minus 40 Grad im Schlafsack und ihr wisst schon.
Das macht die Leute kaputt, das wird sie gar nicht hören.
Nee?
Nee, es gibt da Reality-TV drüber.
Also, für Frauen hat das so eine bizarre Anziehung.
Es gibt ein Reality-TV ernsthaft über Frauen in der Bundeswehr. Ist kein Scheiß jetzt. Das kannst du dir angucken und danach willst du nie wieder irgendwas davon hören.
Ja, wäre freiwillig. Na gut, aber egal.
Wir halten kurz fest, ich betrachte es persönlich als Fortschritt, dass wir keine Zwangsdienste mehr in diesem Land haben. Aber das war wahrscheinlich der Grund, warum sie ihn da hingeschickt haben, weil sie jemanden brauchten, der halbwegs populär ist, der eine relativ strittige, also auch innerhalb der CDU, umstrittene Entscheidung durchdrückt. Weil das Wehrpflicht war ja so ein Ding, was eigentlich sakrosant war. Und das ging ja eigentlich nicht. Das musste aber weg einfach aus Kostengründen. Und die Frage ist ja, wen haben die denn da jetzt noch? Also wenn jetzt der zurücktritt...
Na, die CSU hat überhaupt keinen mehr. Die haben noch den Kauder.
Dann müssen sie irgendwie Seehofer zum Verteidigungsminister machen, oder wie?
Nein, Seehofer auch nicht.
Um Gottes Willen, Seehofer ist weg vom Sensor.
Wir hätten den Generalsekretär, der Duhu Bründ, aber das ist so ein Kleffer. Ihr habt ja bestimmt die Rede gesehen, die eher zur Verteidigung im Bundestag von Gutenberg gern, als so eine Peinlichkeit.
Na die war peinlich.
Der ist auch glaube ich intellektuell nicht auf der Höhe. Der ist eher so ein Schlachtviech. Weißt du, den schickt man in den Balkon.
Das ist doch genau, was du haben willst als Minister.
Als Verteidigungsminister?
Na, aber du brauchst gerade ein Händchen. Also eigentlich brauchst du da eher gerade jemand, der weiß, was er tut.
Na klar.
Na ja, und dann gibt es natürlich noch jemand von Söder. Söder ist ja jetzt sozusagen in der Landespolitik gesundheitlich.
Krieg ich grad so brennen, bist nicht dein Ernst, oder Söder?
Ich meine ja nur, den gibt es noch. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch den Bruder von Kauder, aber der ist ja mittlerweile, das geht auch glaube ich nicht, weil der ist ja nun die Voller-Rüstungslobby ist, den kann man glaube ich nicht zum Verteidigungsminister machen. Also man kann viel...
Na wieso, das ist doch Win-Win.
Ja, könnte man machen. Aber ich weiß nicht, das halte ich für unrealistisch.
Das heißt, das wird die in eine tiefe Personalkrise stürzen.
Haben sie doch aber jetzt schon. Sie haben noch eine Frau bei der CSU, die Hader Tauer, wenn ihr euch erinnert, die mal die Generalsekretärin war. Die soll ja auch noch mit den Füßen scharren.
Und Verteidigungsministerin werden wollen.
Hihihi. Nein, glaube ich aber nicht. Also ich hab jetzt nur so ein bisschen die...
Naja, aber ich meine auch die CDU in Frankreich ging da auch, also...
Auch die CDU sieht ja nicht besser aus. Ist ja nicht ein CSU-Problem.
Sie könnten ja auch gerade machen. Sie könnten sozusagen gerne einen CDU-Verteidigungsminister nehmen. Eben, eben. Eine andere Dressur, zum Beispiel... Wer ist eigentlich der aktuelle Gesundheitsminister? Dieser... Ah nee, das FDP, der geht nicht.
Wer ist der Rössler oder?
Ja, der geht nicht, das FDP.
Ja, das geht mir schon trotzdem.
Na ja, die brauchen ja auch einen im Proporz.
Ja, aber der wird ja nicht wegfallen, sondern bei einer Horade.
Ach, da fällt mir ja noch mal...
Du meinst, sie schieben den Rössler ans Verteidigungsministerium und schieben dann...
Der hat schon genug Leben auf dem Gewiss.
Dann muss ich ja... Ich muss ja übrigens noch was sagen. Wenn wir schon mal beim Zurücktreten sind, ich finde übrigens, also neben der Tatsache, dass Merkel für den Mist zurücktrinken könnte, ist ja da noch eine Ministerin, die mich wirklich ärgert. Hast du dich dazu nicht eräußert. Das eine ist die Schawan als unsere Wissenschaftsministerin. Kann mich die Platze ärgern. Und das andere ist, wo ist eigentlich unser Bundespräsident?
Hm, haben wir einen?
Ja, wir haben einen.
Ich hatte immer das Gerücht von, der ist in Belgien.
Für immer?
Naja, also...
Wie der Kaiser? Wie unser letzter Kaiser. Also mich ärgert, dass... Also die Bildungspolitikerin, die übrigens auch wirklich... Also ich meine, das ist eine wirkliche Wissenschaftlerin.
Aber da haben wir doch eine offensichtliche Theorie, warum da nichts passiert. Das liegt doch auf der Hand. Na, die haben alle Angst, dass jemand ihre Doktorarbeiten anguckt.
Ist doch klar. Also bei Annette Schawan bin ich mir sehr sicher, dass das mal wirklich eine Wissenschaftlerin war. Die hat ja da auch viel gearbeitet. Und außerdem, wenn du die mal reden hörst, die ist...
Harte Hand und Fuß, meinst du?
Ja. Aber wie kann die dazu schweigen? Das ist eine Frechheit. Die braucht von keinem von diesen Sülzen will ich mir noch jemals was über Bildungspolitik an. Also die anderen doof. Was soll ich den meinen Studenten erzählen? Wenn dieser gegehte Betrüger da bleibt. Ich bitte dich unterhalten. Ich rege mich schon wieder auf. Ich brauch mal Beruhigung.
Aber deswegen machen wir das ja hier.
Ach so, damit man mal eben darüber reden kann.
Im Grunde wollen wir genau diese Ansage treffen. Wenn dieser Typ im Amt bleibt, dann haben wir nichts mehr, um den nächsten Generationen zu erklären, warum sie nicht bescheißen sollen. Ja, das ist ein Dammbruch.
Und nicht mehr die Fassade bleibt.
Nicht nur in der Wissenschaft, sondern auch generell gesellschaftlich ist einfach der Wert von eigener Leistung nur dann was wert, wenn man es auch respektiert. Und das tut dieser Gutenberg eben gerade nicht. Und deswegen muss er zurücktreten und nicht nur seinen Titel niederlegen, was er wohl eine Pfarr ist, sondern gleich ist.
Ja, und der ist offensichtlich ein Lügner.
Ein Lügner ist er auch noch, ja. Aber da kann man sagen, okay, war halt eine Notlüge. Also da gibt es Leute, die irgendwie sagen würden, na gut, ich will nicht sagen, dass ich das irgendwie verteidige, aber weißt du, das ist nicht irgendwie...
Es entspricht zumindest der Berufsbezeichnung.
Genau, das erwartet man von Politiker nicht anders, als dass sie lügen, ehrlich gesagt. Also wenn Politiker zurücktreten müssen, weil sie lügen, dann haben wir keine mehr.
Es gibt nicht so sehr viele Politiker, die so offensichtliche Lügen überlebt haben. Der Koch hatte mit seinen, ihr wisst schon, die Vermächtnisse.
Die jüdischen Vermächtnisse, ja.
Genau. Also so viele Politiker gibt es nicht, die sowas aussitzen konnten, aber das ist ja...
Na ja, die blühenden Landschaften, ich meine, ich habe schon einige Beispiele von Leuten, die eine Weile überlebt haben.
Das ist keine Lüge, das ist kognitive.
Das ist eine normale Berufsweihepolitik.
Genau, das ist okay. Na ja, gut. Haben wir jetzt noch etwas Wichtiges vergessen von unserem Jahr? Wir wollten doch über die funktionalen Analphabeten in der Akademie reden.
Aber ich glaube, das ist noch mal ein extra Podcast. Da brauchen wir noch mal einen zweiten Rechtschreib.
Die Sanktionen haben wir eigentlich besprochen. Die sind nicht wirklich vorhanden. Natürlich gibt es zivile und strafrechtliche Sachen. Wir haben jetzt alle über die Urteile gelesen. Auch die Degradierung bei der Bundeswehr-Universität haben wir ja auch gelesen. Da braucht man glaube ich nichts mehr zu sagen.
Kann man den Gutenberg eigentlich degradieren? Hat der einen Dienstgrad innerhalb der?
Nein, die Minister sind grundsätzlich immer nicht Dienstgrad gebunden. Zivile Führung ist auch eigentlich okay. Also es ist halt vernünftig.
Ja gut, wir müssen noch was sagen. Ich glaube, wir sollten sagen...
Im Übrigen sind wir der Meinung, dass Gutenberg zurücktreten muss.
Genau.
Dann, bis zum nächsten Mal.